all right switching over oh it's weird hello hello hi what's
her greeting again i always know like dentsia later yeah and
mvp sal but what's the greeting condense no koya condense
condense condense condense everybody Condense, condense,
condense.
Yippee!
We're working today.
You guys, I have a confession.
I enlisted you in this game.
Because Densetsu is going to shut down if we don't make
enough money.
It's love life.
I mean, the idol group is going to shut down.
You need to make money.
Yeah, the school is going to...
I mean, the idol group is going to shut down.
The school!
The idol school.
The silly idol school.
Yeah.
Right.
Sensei Academy is gonna shut down and we have to make money
for it.
We do.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I'll do anything.
Any ideas of how we're gonna make money?
Anything.
Don't say that.
Anything!
We're gonna make you eat tubs and tubs of cheese balls and
become a mukbang channel.
Cheese bugs!
Sorry, I've been...
Loki, I've been seeing so many bugs over the past day that I
think I Freudian slipped that.
Oh, no.
Wait, Phoebe...
It was one that had many legs that was chasing me through
the bathroom.
Ew!
Oh, ew!
Yeah, real quick question for Phoebe.
Are you using your correct microphone?
Is that what you were about to ask?
Yeah, I was just about...
I should be.
This keeps peeking and, like, making, like, a...
Scratchy sound.
It's going, like...
Is it still making a weird scratchy sound?
It's only when you get really...
Try shower.
Oh god.
I'm scared.
Ah!
Oh god.
Yes.
Hold on.
The bugs are in the system you guys.
Is this better?
Try yelling again?
Shout again?
Ah!
Oh that's good.
Oh so much better.
So much better.
That's perfect.
Oh you know what it was?
I put a setting on my interface because I thought I'd be too
quiet.
without without it and it boosts your mic by 10 decibels oh
i think you can turn yourself up a little bit now yeah oh i
oh okay i wonder you're a choto shizuka yeah yeah a choto i
can i can only put the gain up so let me say hello is this
better oh okay oh i'm so i'm so sorry hello Ah, ah, hello.
Is it too much now?
No, I think it's good.
Shout again.
I love hearing you shout.
Ah!
Oh, God.
I think it's just the right amount that we can hear you
well, and it's got a bit of ambiance when you yell.
A little bit of ambiance.
Peeing.
Or the horror game.
Oh, for the horror game.
Yeah.
And my chat, you can tell me, too, if the balance is good.
Yeah, same as well.
Yeah.
Victory screech.
Homegirl's talking out of the kazoo.
Oh, it's better now.
I'm not kazoo voice anymore, I hope.
Yeah, you're good.
It did sound like a really like a shrill kazoo.
It was like, Yeah.
Oh, no.
Hopefully this is good now.
No.
Speaking of kazoo, there we are.
We need our special items to get us through the night.
Oh, do it.
Should I get mine?
I'm ready.
What, what, okay, that's your special item.
What is, what's Minto's special item?
Oh, oh.
Uh, uh, hold on.
I can grab it.
I'll go into it.
Oh, take your time.
I think my special, my special item is that moth on the wall
right there.
Probably.
Oh, it's beautiful.
Wait, I left them on the side.
I hear it.
Oh.
Oh, is it also a chimkin?
It sounds like it could be.
It is a chicken.
Oh, it's like a little one.
It's a little one that is.
That's the Vicky Govind chicken.
Oh, yeah, we all got little ones.
Yeah.
Cute, cute, cute, cute.
My little one is at home.
Oh, that's okay.
That's okay.
I've got some bugs.
Some bugs.
Yippee!
I'm just surrounded by I have been surrounded by bugs who
have the past day That's just my life.
Oh, I see actual bugs.
Okay.
Well, I'm looking forward to them going to say hello Oh, I
hope not I mean they may come it may gently come say hello
There really was one with lots of legs that that was like a
centipede line No, no, no, but the long like hairy looking
legs Yeah, it was well, it was like the one with the legs
that go or like antennae or legs that go all around its body
it's not quite a centipede yeah they're like sticking out
yeah yeah terrifying I'm gonna try not to think about it but
yeah we're we're with our chickens and our bugs in tow we're
going to make money and save the idle group yeah money yeah
So how many of you played this game?
None, I think.
Phoebe, okay, so we literally don't know what we're doing or
anything.
Wait, I know, I know.
Okay, I know.
Okay, Phoebe also kind of knows a little bit the idea.
Basically, okay.
What, wait, what animals did you guys pick?
A puppy.
Oh, is that important?
Oh, I picked the goose.
I picked the goose.
I had a feeling.
I was going to pick, I was going to pick the goose.
Why did I think you would also pick the goose?
is like I was gonna pick the goose but I knew that I knew
that you guys were gonna pick the goose so I picked
something else because I thought that it mattered.
Oh but other than that I was like I should just pick the
goose then if we're all gonna be geese.
We're silly geese.
I think you could still change well actually maybe maybe I
think maybe if you leave the lobby you can change it but
that's okay.
Do they give you powers?
I don't know.
Does it give you power?
But
have to work a job to get money for your goose slash dog but
it's you know vicky you know papers please yeah it's a
little bit like that where we're running a store but there
are doppelgangers there are fake creepy people coming in and
we have to yeah we have to interrogate them and be like are
you the real person that you actually are while also
managing our store That sounds like a lot just like walk
into the combini and they're like, are you really Victoria
Roman?
Are you really?
That information.
It's actually, yeah, I mean, that would be the case.
How would we tell?
Oh yeah, what's, if it's based on how human they seem, I'm
not sure if any of us are very good at identifying.
None of us are human.
Victoria Roman, say something only Victoria Roman would say.
Oh, is that the kind of thing we've got to ask?
Shadow the Hedgehog!
The most obvious answer.
Most obvious, but also the most simple.
Yeah.
You know it's me.
Then you know it's me.
Phoebe Chan Cheeby say something only Phoebe Chan Cheeby
would say.
Six, seven.
Oh, my.
I know.
Miss Victoria Roman would also say that.
Victoria Roman skin walking as Phoebe scary oh wow wow
wowzers Wowzers mint phantom say something only mint phantom
would say six seven don't you don't imposter imposter
imposter we found them I can't believe she actually said it
Right?
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Hey guys, we just got to the collab.
How's it going?
No, this fake Minto!
What have you done with the real Minto?
Oh no.
Well, so what happens in this game when we identify skin
walkers?
Yeah, shoot them.
You just shoot them.
Damn.
Yeah, you just take them out.
I mean, if it was the real Minto, she just like, it would
just go right through her, right?
Oh, true.
True.
even though we were wrong.
But if it was the fake myth, then...
I just saw the real answer in my chat.
Bring back the dinosaur ride at Disney World.
Like, that's how you know.
Something only Minto would say.
Surely there are others that want the dinosaur ride to come
back.
No way, but I was looking at...
I have like something that I was given that is from the
dinosaur ride and I was looking at it today and I was like,
I missed the dinosaur ride.
right so it really is that's real that's real so real so
real so okay so we so sorry if they're an imposter we shoot
them did you say yeah well there's probably other various
ways we could probably hammer them we could shoot them we
could blow them up i'm sure there's lots of okay
accidentally blow up a civilian well kind of used to blowing
up anyway anyway anyway yeah guys we just need to get rid of
loiterers that's what we're doing tonight yes that's what
we're doing yeah with extreme measures
it's not a day in the life of densetsu today i suppose yeah
this is also our duty is to protect akiba Mm-hmm.
Maybe we'll need the Konveni and Akiba.
Akiba looking kind of different.
I don't know.
Very vegetation.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is part of our plan to re-invigorate Akiba.
Oh my god, I had to put ready this whole...
Oh, no, it's okay.
It's okay.
No, no, I wasn't ready either.
Are you guys ready though?
Do you want to try it out?
I just saw you guys suddenly do it and I was like, like what
no you're good okay yeah should we should we try i'm excited
to try yes bring it on imposter's america 1993 oh i can't
hear them moy moy boo everybody welcome in thank you that
didn't say america guys what do you mean it didn't oh out
tonight you will get customers you must figure out whether
or not they are doppelganger Apple gangers okay I am Greg
use the computer oh database base always shows correct what
if someone's hacking the database I'm sorry this is not oh
how do we know wait but this person has one arm and this
Greg has no has both arms Greg Davies the Greg Davies Davies
Greg lucker Wow I would like to manifest MVP on Taskmaster
one day.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Yeah!
I'm guessing it's that Greg Davis.
Okay.
Question customers to determine if they are doppelgangers.
My arm actually grew back two days ago.
Discuss with your friends and decide if you think the
customer is a doppelganger.
If you suspect the worst, locate the gun beneath the counter
and shoot.
Boom, headshot.
Oh, I think they're all...
If you are notified that a doppelganger left this door,
you'd better board up, lay traps, and hide.
Oh, dear.
So if we miss one, then we're screwed, basically.
We won't miss.
I never miss.
No way.
Wait, no way that you guys are actually your colored shirts.
Wait, what color is my shirt?
Woohoo!
Greed.
We got...
and green and green.
And green.
It's okay.
You guys have two different shades of green.
I will surely be able to distinguish.
You look so dejected.
You're like, ugh.
I'm so sad.
That's my blue shirt.
It's okay.
You can change it next round.
Yeah, probably.
There's a way.
Orr.
Squatting outside the combination.
Yeah, yeah.
We can.
Objective is the head inside.
We can go in, we can like sit out there and be like, no
doppelgangers getting in.
Now look at this classic Akihabara combini.
Yeah, it's like 7-11.
Hey, wait, the colors are kind of pink, green, and blue.
Oh, a little bit, yeah.
Read the instruction on the notice board.
Notice board.
The toilet?
I'm going to go in the toilet.
Why are we going to the bathroom to look at the notes?
Oh, I had.
Oh, you can be...
What is that?
Oh, confound.
Wait, there's tokens.
Oh, here.
There's more tokens.
Wait, there's tons of tokens.
Do we share the tokens?
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding.
Oh, wow.
That's just me.
Sorry, that's just me.
Welcome to the crappy patty.
I was testing it.
I found a copy machine.
I found some trash.
Oh.
Um...
Benz will eject you if you stay inside.
Wait, will it eject me?
I thought I was gonna eat me.
What's happening?
What?
I might have found some, uh, suspicious meat.
Suspicious meat?
Saying to whack the meat.
Whack it.
I don't have a sledgehammer.
Oh, come on.
Lettuce.
How do you whack things?
It looks like you need a hammer.
No, it says a hammer.
Oh, there's a big spider.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay, thank goodness we're out of there.
It's so fuzzy.
It's really fuzzy for some reason.
You guys, get into the, go into the vent.
This is the kind of stuff that's been happening to me over
the past day.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh.
Day.
Go in the vent and like just chill in there.
It's really cozy.
Yeah.
Oh, it feels so cozy.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's really nice in here.
Oh, ew, oh!
Ow!
Oh, what?
Ew, what?
I feel like I'm having a great time.
I don't know what's happening with these.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
It's a great time.
Yeah, I, um, yes, I might have.
Was it the same thing as us?
Is it the same thing as a town?
I think it is the same thing.
Do you have mystery meat coming from the ceiling?
Yes.
Oh, so that's where the mystery meat came from.
Yeah, I guess so.
Endless supply.
We, yeah, we should harvest it and sell it.
We can get Cobra Cola.
Yeah.
Cobra Cola.
Would you buy mystery meat burgers?
totally not sus what are you I'm cleaning you because you
were covered in die the burger buns pink and green and blue
so special merch item oh yeah come here they're like crabby
bad oh clean me you're covered in squeaky clean yes you're
so squeaky clean I can't hug you anymore because you just
slip away I know now I'm like so slippery I'm squeaking I
don't know why does it look like this It was like...
Strange noodles.
Why is that animation?
I know, right?
Oh.
Look at it!
Why does it wiggle like that?
Oh.
You're mopping, obviously.
Yeah.
Obviously.
I'm gonna read the instructions.
Yeah, I'm gonna go read the instructions.
instructions yeah what is the notice board where I found it
it's in here employee to do use trash bags to throw out the
limbs in the storage room mop the blood restock the
incomplete shelf with boxes oh great okay easy wait what's
this doppelgangers continue to ravage America throughout the
night doppelganger sightings increase experts advise
checking ID and personal details when interacting Oh my god,
infinite mobs, infinite mobs.
There's so many of them.
Did they despawn?
Can we break the game if we have too many mobs?
I think they despawn.
They despawn.
Ah, darn it.
Trashback, show out the limbs.
Limbs.
I'm grabbing some limbs.
We stocked the incomplete shelf with boxes.
Boxes.
I got some limbs.
Limbs on Alphab.
Oh, you guys got the limbs already?
Oh.
Eer limbs.
I'll just I'll just come with then okay it's kind of spooky
out here where we put the trash trash is over here there's
your way oh ah dumpster diving Diane was here money throw
out the trash throw out the trash praise the entity infinite
trash The... Have you guys seen any blood?
Oh, oh, I see.
No, no, no.
This blood might have been it.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm mopping.
I'm mopping so well.
Oh, you're mopping?
You got it?
Oh, yeah.
Look at her go.
Wow.
Look at me mopping up that ketchup.
And then we restock.
Okay, okay, where?
Oh, restock.
Oh.
Wait.
I'm such a... Such a pro at mopping.
Restock the incomplete shells.
Wait, was that a customer?
Oh, is it?
Oh, no, sorry, that was my fat ass.
Oh, okay.
Wait, I can't see what I have.
Wait, oh.
Restock the incomplete box.
How do we know which ones are incomplete?
I'm not sure.
I just found one.
Wait, where was it?
I think it's the yellow.
Yeah, this yellow one.
Oh, I can't select it.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I'm really slow.
There's, like, so much to...
do here.
Okay.
Box empty.
Where are the boxes?
Are there other boxes?
It's still yellow, though.
Shelf already full.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, I think we all have to do the same one.
Rack products onto the shelf.
Where did you get the box from, though?
In the back here.
Oh, wait.
There were only two boxes.
Oh.
Read the instructions on the checkout counter.
I helped.
I cured you one.
Yeah, you did.
We just leave the products on the floor without it messing.
I'll open it in the back.
Hmm.
Computer's database is always true.
There's no such thing as misinformation on the internet.
And then if you spot any inconsistencies or blatant lies,
locate the gun and shoot.
Didn't say what to shoot.
To shoot a warning shot into the air.
I don't know.
I don't do warning shots.
Oh!
Ah!
A real person!
Oh wow.
Well now, you must be the new night clerk.
Welcome to the graveyard shift, my friend.
It's probably a little daunting, huh?
Fly.
No worries.
Let me give you a rundown of how it's done.
First, scan my ID on the counter.
Okay.
Oh, I scan.
I've got his info.
Oh, you do?
you do what's his address yeah his address uh doesn't say
his date of birth is the 15th of april 1939.
he's a sheriff often in uniform visible in id photo often
wears glasses is the info we got just washed them last night
good luck finding me out of uniform i'm trying to find a
good place for me guys he says he's often in uniform he is
in uniform are you alive Are you alive?
Can't tell if he's alive.
Maybe that too.
Is your name...
Oh,
he's got a...
I respect the muscle.
He's old, guys.
He's old, yeah.
Question his occupation.
My head, I haven't lost it again, have I?
Wait!
Wait, are you perhaps...
Are you perhaps...
One of me?
of me do you lose your head i think he's good then right so
or does he might be one of you a question is occupation uh
oh what's your okay oh occupation sheriff is of the best
town in the west interact with him oh what are your limbs
like 250 pounds of pure muscle ha ha you're so right
Okay, you are.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, he's not losing his head when we do this.
You're lobotomizing it.
Wait, from this angle, it kind of looks like you're giving
him hair.
Like...
Only happy thoughts.
Oh, yes, get re-haired, re-haired.
Grow, grow, grow.
Question his occupation.
Yeah, you have to do that on the computer.
Oh.
You click on the occupation.
Yeah.
clean get clean i see the transaction okay all in one
service you come in you get your food you get clean gun
unlocked yeah oh yeah guys look lively our first customer
hello that you think she's safe hey there long night at the
hospital just need to grab a few things and head home
Nurse and bald.
I'm already suspicious.
Look at that date of birth, everyone.
Suspicious.
Wait, why?
Very suspicious.
Stopped.
What's her name?
Shirley?
Yes.
Bonnie.
Oh.
Whoa.
Are you really born in 1967, Bonnie McCree?
That's a value of this.
really sauce very sauce indeed reading glasses i took them
off before heading in here i don't know you look great 19
watch in 1966 seven sorry suspicious i think she's fine i
think she's fine to be fair that does seem to be it does
seem to be how she feels sometimes wears glasses over
sometimes the fifth 1993 minus six seven how much is that 50
that's like he took off her reading glasses 26 she's like 26
it says only sometimes it wears glasses may i have a a
sherlock theory yeah why would you take off your reading
glasses before entering the combini where there are many
magazines huh oh things to read huh yeah seems very
suspicious it does i think she's fine though i think no i
think she is probably fine i think she's probably fine i'll
take her money just take the money Bye-bye.
Give her a good scrub down.
Oh.
Did I say money?
Following these people throughout the city.
Where'd he go?
Just grabbing some stuff real quick.
No big deal.
Nathan, huh?
Give him a good look.
Yeah, I am.
I am.
Cool off, bro.
Whoa, it's swinging.
Don't call me bro.
My limbs and something wrong with my limbs.
What is this ID?
I, wait, guys.
You said I just got these clothes.
Isn't that very weird?
That is weird.
Wait, oh, what's his?
Wait!
His name is Nathan Calloway.
No, his ID is fake.
And he's deceased!
Oh!
Yeah!
Smith.
Oh my god.
No.
Get it done.
Excuse the mess.
So sorry.
We're...
Excuse us.
Sorry for the inconvenience.
How do we bag up the...
I got you.
Don't let him see.
We're gonna... I'm gonna repackage it.
I'll put it out for the goods.
There was another limb.
Wait, a delivery has arrived.
It's alright, I've got it, I've got it.
I've got the other one.
Where's the bin?
Wait, what is the delivery?
Hello.
Do you see that?
See what?
Do you actually...
Nothing.
See what, though?
Wait, see what, bitch?
Do you see that?
Wait, do you see that?
Oh my god, it's right there.
there wait no seriously vicky right in front of us right
there wait no i don't see nothing straight straight ahead
straight ahead oh oh i yeah okay i do see a figure of a
person yeah damn she does not perceive you dude that was
freaking me out you guys they're like hey was it less freaky
after you saw it open the baby gate they say let it replace
you let it replace you is this it
hello what what did we border i don't know oh oh oh oh oh
jesus oh wait freaking oh did you get the spiders the gun
when the customers arrive oh on the phone um hey man i'm
just down the the road from your store my car won't start I
really need a hand getting it running again can you come out
and help me oh what go down the road and help I'm sorry we
should be paid I don't think we get paid enough no we don't
I got the gun and yet you still go outside I've got the gun
I've got the gun bring the gun I've got the gun show bring
the gun oh my god is broken Traps?
Oh my god!
Oh, it's gone.
Close some of these doors.
Oh, what, you think the doors need to be closed?
Yeah, I mean, there's so many entrances for them to come.
That's true, that's true.
Maybe we should set up the traps, right?
Hang on, guys, where'd she go?
Okay, there she is.
Where are the traps?
They're right here.
I got one, I got one.
Hey there, cutie.
Oh, oh.
Oh, hello.
place oh hi hi juliet hi who's this um hello julieta hi hi
hi julieta the plumber oh wait no no you're that's wrong
where's the gun i can't oh do it do it baby she ate the
python and do it you gotta do it boy she's just following
her dreams and and it's chose a different career path wait
what is she what is she oh no Plumber?
She's supposed to be a janitor Or plant plumber.
What happened?
I've been a flight attendant for Three years.
It's a steady job.
Keeps me You gotta do it to her.
Couldn't she Be a plumber on the plane?
Oh, yeah.
On the plane.
Hold on.
Let's see how she looks with this Mop.
Yeah.
How does she work with the Mop?
How does it look?
How does she look with the Mop?
Does it fit her?
Does it suit her?
Do you think?
Guys, but her birthday is also 1969.
Suspicious.
Do it, Phoebe.
Headshot.
I'm sorry.
Do it.
Oh!
Do it again!
Whoa!
Wait, what does that mean?
Does that mean she wasn't...
What she want?
No, no.
She had to abandon.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
Was she a skinwalker?
Yeah, yeah, she was.
Yeah, yeah.
Can I just like...
Okay.
Oh, Kevin, Kevin Larson.
You're an insurance sales and you wear formal wear and
you're tall.
He's in...
In-game chat.
Hmm.
Oh, T to open dialogue.
T?
Oh, yes, Kevin.
I asked Kevin about being tall and Kevin said, Just blessed
with good genes, I suppose.
She was a creature.
She said, you creatures will pay for this.
Oh, she said that!
Oh, nice.
Yeah, okay, thank God.
Is he that tall?
How tall is he next to me?
Kevin.
Kevin, I love you.
I love your way of thinking.
Yeah, blessed with good genes.
I agree, Kevin.
I think Kevin's fine.
I'm accepting the transaction.
Yeah, I like Kevin.
He's a cool guy.
school he's normal sized give staff a raise I agree I agree
oh I think Kevin's name is beef he gave us a good review
yeah beef yeah thanks Kevin yeah five stars on y'all oh we
got how's your purchase how's your purchase how's your
purchase.
Oh my god, I was in the combini earlier.
Bartholomew.
Okay, right.
That's the name of the rhinoceros.
They kept being like, Inno Chai Masu!
Inno Chai Masu!
He didn't have exact change which would optimize this
transaction.
Bartholomew's.
He's an electronic source.
How many workers were not forward head posture.
I guess he does have a gamer hump yeah yeah here I'll get
this away from you Bartholomew is your skin beautiful oh
yeah extended seating toss encouraged forward positions yeah
that's fair enough Bob on me okay so I'm a little suspicious
of is his I'm suspicious of his birthday what's that 74 of
his birthday he would be like 20 something right I'm also so
suspicious of his birthday yeah why is the month first
before the day i'm suspicious of that
march 12th 1974 3 42 a.m if precision matters okay buddy
actually at this point though wouldn't he be like wouldn't
he be like 19 or something oh it'd be night well maybe
that's the acne he just yeah maybe that's why he has acne
but also i don't know he looks like you got gamer posture
like that already look he'd be hang on hang on let me do the
maths he'd be 19 no some some people don't age well i know
right no no no i feel bad but he's judging him for his
appearance it is a rough 19 sorry buddy i feel like we can't
i feel like the information is correct i think it's be
correct yeah we're we're we're being we're being harsh it's
it's just you know yeah all right i'm accepting the
transaction oh we're done lovely oh okay not any messes
what's the messes what's messes we got like i guess we can
restock maybe oh no it won't let me never just kidding bye
bar for me oh i do have some i wonder what cobra cola is for
I want to know...
Watch this.
Ouch!
Oh!
My bad!
I'm okay!
Are you okay?
What was that?
Well, I set up a trap.
Um...
But it, you know...
You had to test it first, I suppose.
Yeah, yeah.
Does it work?
It did.
It worked.
Oh good.
Just don't try and jump over them.
You won't do it.
Oh, guys.
Guys, I am... Wow.
I'm invincible.
You're invincible?
Yeah.
How'd you do it?
So powerful.
Whoa.
Maybe you're not... Maybe you're the imposter.
Oh, yeah.
Please don't shoot me.
Here.
I'm the imposter.
The British among...
The British amongst the Americans.
Yeah.
You think we're gonna get chased out then?
Yeah, I guess so, right?
Um, hopefully not.
Yeah, wonder what goes on in here.
Out, out, out and about.
Oh yeah.
The dentist never left.
I hope we cleaned up all of that.
How long does the map go on for?
Let it replace you.
Wait, you guys are so far!
Yeah, this is scary.
He's dark.
It's scary.
Does it eat noodle stick?
Does it eat noodle stick is a good question.
I'm ready to go home.
Oh, there's the bus.
Yeah.
I'm going home.
Oh, good.
Public transportation.
Beep, beep, beep.
Head home.
Still working even after all this.
Oh, the bus waited for us this whole time.
That's so nice.
That is so nice.
That is really nice.
Oh, yeah.
We did it!
Yippee!
Awesome!
That perfect run!
Nice.
Great job, guys.
Two days remain until Suki's next medical bill.
Two days remain until Herbert's next medical bill.
Two days remain until Goose's next medical bill.
I feel like the names of our pets say a lot.
all right next shift next shift baby if question about her
reading glasses she says she took them off before coming
yeah yeah i like that it tells you i know right it's a new
night check the notice board new night i'm feeling good
bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom oh the notice board oh
there's But there's no spider web anymore.
That's good.
Oh, we got cleaned!
Oh my god.
There's so much.
West Bridge shot down.
Oh, there.
Oh, yeah.
So much money.
There's so much money.
Give me... Yes, give me the coins.
Give me the coins.
Ooh, a flashlight for some reason.
Oh, what's this?
Give me the coins.
Oh, bear trap is in my way.
Excuse me, bear trap.
Whoa, what's this?
is it can we spin it whoa gotcha wait what's it say oh my
gosh can we can we spin it thanks to the recent construction
complications of westbridge have been entirely closed oh oh
are you spinning yet can we have a customer oh oh oh oh two
oh oh because i think we lost more coins than we earned but
that's okay is it a shared amount of coins made a little bit
back it's a good question oh Oh, um...
Are they okay?
Whoa!
He's aggressive!
Language!
Retired and living the dream, okay?
Shut up and ring.
I don't see a mustache.
Do you?
On a hem?
I don't either.
Oh.
Hey Mr. Oh wait, no, I do I see it.
I see it.
I think I think that guy outside is a little closer today I
think he's a little bit closer closer Yeah, the guy outside
ignore him ignore him.
I just ignore him.
Okay, I'll ignore him and his meat blob I think he's fine
though.
I think this guy's fine.
Oh, he hates something drunk and rude.
He's upset about something What do you say?
What did he say?
Hello?
He's like...
Isle signs.
Oh, that's kind of mean.
Yeah.
Oh, I want a small plant.
You want to get smacked.
Oh, you want to get smacked.
Oh my god.
Roger, please.
He is right though.
Plagger.
It's true.
Wait, his...
Even his signature is bad.
Delivery has arrived.
Yeah, I ordered a plant.
I ordered a plant.
Give it to me.
I think he is, in fact, normal.
I'm gonna accept his transaction, all right?
Okay.
Yeah, I think he's just drunk.
Yeah.
Do we know where the loading bay gate is?
I already got it.
It's, like, right out here.
Wow!
Oh, bro, bro.
The guy outside is closer.
Right, right?
Why are you running?
Why are you running, huh?
He also was rolling a flesh ball at us.
What?
Praise the entity.
A flesh ball.
Hey there, boss.
Hope your nights go in smoothly.
Derek.
Postal worker.
Jogs every...
He did.
Always wears his orange jacket showing an ID photo.
He is wearing that.
Guys, where's the delivery?
Oh, I already got it.
I already got it.
But...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it shows up in the garage.
Oh.
So what's the point of decor?
points oh hey there boss hoping night's going smoothly hmm
this guy's a little too friendly for my life does it look
closer oh and he rolled that you want to play soccer hmm hmm
oh who leaves all their money outside you know you're I
think he looks normal, right?
I think he looked normal.
I think so.
Oh, decorations.
Yeah, I got the plant for her decoration.
You got a plant?
It's nice.
This little guy right here.
Yeah, yeah.
Really brightens up the place.
I'm gonna go do some gotcha.
It really does.
Feel free.
I'm gonna maybe...
Oh, ten bucks.
A nice brick as a decoration.
No, destroys flesh.
No, never mind.
Um...
I'll sign I want it Look at it, check out me out Guys, I
made this money On the Gacha Hey, yeah Hey, great Hey, nice
Oh, wait Did you just get this nice hat From the Gacha?
Oh, oh, no, I think Vinto did Min buy that?
No?
Oh, I got it from the hat.
I'm never going to play gotcha ever again.
Oh, from here?
Oh, I want a hat.
I know, right.
We'll get a hat.
I'll get it right now.
What?
Oh, almost so close.
So close.
Why would I do that to us?
Yeah.
Wow.
Oh, this is working out well for us so far.
So far.
Let's spin it.
YAHOO!
We just keep winning.
We can't stop winning.
Spin it.
Get it hat.
Don't mind if I eat my dinner.
Yeah, go for it.
Of course.
No, please eat.
I forgot that's in front of me and it's getting stalled.
We got a little guy!
Little guy?
Oh wait, Phoebe, you need the little guy.
I think you...
It looks so cute.
Oh, oh my god!
Wait, put it on, put it on!
Do we all get it?
Or...
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, we do!
Oh, no!
We do!
Oh, yes, we do!
No, we do, we do!
How do we access it?
You go into the hat locker.
Yeah, the hat locker here and you scroll up.
Oh, heck yeah.
Money!
What's our quota today?
35, we've already reached it.
reached it oh how do we let him go do we just tell him to go
oh yeah you have to um basically the register you click the
register yeah yep i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i
was just waiting i'm so sorry this guy has a gun yeah it's
ratatouille hat wait it's old snake wait why are you putting
that oh no yes Do you like your life?
Fill the bag with money if you want you to see your family
again.
Oh, do it.
Do it.
Fill the bag with money?
No.
Fill the store with his guts.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, scary.
Okay, let's go as a team.
I'm going to clean.
What was that?
Go outside.
Where outside?
The generator, no?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the generator out there.
Oh, here.
All hands are needed.
Phoebe, we need you!
Phoebe!
Phoebe, we need your strength!
Oh, why is he...
Phoebe!
Phoebe, we need you!
We need you!
Okay, call me.
Oh, you need me to do it too?
Yeah!
Okay, I'm all hands on deck.
Oh, there we go.
All hands.
Good job.
Oh, I'm mocked.
Who has the gun?
Hey, yeah, get him
A pirate hat.
That's a great gift.
Well, what if he's just really tall?
Do you need help sir?
Can I help you?
He's the new guy.
It's like from back rooms.
I don't think we need a yellow member.
in Densatsu.
I mean...
Does he talk?
We're gonna spread out the heights a little more.
I'm all for it.
Oh, wait.
Does he talk?
I can see the indention of his cheeks.
Dang.
Holy cow.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Oh, damn.
Um...
Okay, I need to pick up the guts outside.
Oh, okay, I'll shoot him.
I got important things to do.
You're gonna shoot him?
Well, what else am I gonna do?
Do you have to?
I don't know.
Sorry.
Do we have to?
Maybe he's doing all right.
We're trying to turn down the audio.
It's so loud when, uh, hold on.
Maybe I- But I feel like we kind of have to, right?
Yeah, I think so.
I got him!
Thank you.
I feel bad.
It seemed all right.
It wouldn't even do anything.
But nobody, he wasn't- I don't know.
Nobody was coming in.
Oh, yeah.
They were like waiting for him to leave.
They're like, oh, that guy again.
Oh, you guys got it.
Okay.
Yeah, I got it.
There's trash bags here.
There's trash bags right here, too.
They're right outside.
Oh, what's wrong, Grace?
Life won't give me a break today.
Oh, Grace.
You can take a break here with something.
Yeah.
The West Bridge.
The West Bridge is fun.
Did he look closer?
Yeah, don't mind.
I think he's closer.
The earlier.
That's kind of spooky.
Is Grace good?
I'm sorry I can't be bothered with all this.
Well, we can be bothered.
We can be bothered.
You look so menacing next to her.
She is a single mother.
Wait, this really is backroomed.
We got the pirate hat and everything.
Oh, it's true.
She's having a hard life.
Guys, look at her face.
That's a bit more than...
I think she looks the...
Dark circles, isn't it?
No, I think she looks the same.
11th of the 4th.
What, a fringe or, like...
I think she's okay.
No, like, if you look at her close up on her face, she's
got, like, purple.
Oh, yeah, she's got a bruise on her face.
You're right.
Yay!
What does that mean?
Oh, but it's not...
Was it that deadbeat guy?
I don't know.
Do we kill her?
But she said to her, the kids' husband left.
I mean, the kids' father left, though.
Wait, it disappears and then it reappears because I don't
see it anymore.
Yeah, do you think it's just the lighting?
Okay, let's just assume it's the lighting and think she's
okay.
Oh, yeah, it's the lighting.
It's the lighting.
I think she's not okay, but in like some other ways.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's the lighting.
When she turns her head, I see the shadows, like, move
around, yeah.
Oh, I see.
Hang in there.
You got this, Grace.
You got this.
Oh, oops.
Wait, bag all the items first.
Wait, maybe we clicked it at the same time.
Hello there.
Hello.
Oh my god, that was literally me in the con meeting before.
Oh, my one thing with this dude is like, he's very shy.
Oh god, yeah, why is he so shy?
Listen up.
Would you like to try restocking?
The world will end if we don't sleep together right now!
Wait, what?
What?
Dilbert!
Hickerman!
What the?
Huh?
His signature!
Bilbert, you're a bit weird.
Wait, why wouldn't it let me exit?
I could take good care of you.
Ew!
Let me exit.
It's just a bit of oil.
Nothing to worry about.
It was in his ears and everything.
Wait, I'm trying to see his eyes.
Oh, my God.
It won't let me move.
Is it letting you guys move?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Why are you guys fused together?
I can't move.
I'm just staring at Dilbert.
Are you in a conversation with him?
I think we gotta kill him.
No, no.
Dilbert's just, uh...
Is my game bugging out?
No, I hate this.
I can't.
Here, I'll get rid of Dilbert.
I'll get rid of Dilbert.
There we go.
Okay, thank God.
Oh, wait, now I let you move?
Yeah.
Now I let you move.
Okay, good.
Or we go Dilbert's fault.
Whoa!
This guy!
Yeah, duh.
Oh!
Ugh!
Wait, oh wait.
Maybe he's...
He's fine.
He's stealing stuff?
Look at the way he runs.
Oh, hello.
He's a silly little, silly little guy.
He is so silly.
Oh, I like him.
I like him too.
Hi.
He's gonna pay for it, right?
If he's gonna pay for it, right?
If he doesn't shoot.
Maybe if he doesn't shoot.
Uh-huh, I'm getting ready.
Yeah, get ready.
Get ready.
Because he's grabbing a lot of stuff.
Hmm.
Where's our mop?
I hope there's no friendly fire.
I'm not very good at aiming.
You can test it on me.
I am Nova.
Is that all for today?
Scan unsuccessful.
Fake ID.
Just these items, please.
Norbert.
I will scan these items right away from you, my friend.
I had some customer like you, no problem at all.
I don't see any Nova.
Orbit on the database.
Do I shoot this guy?
I like him too much to shoot him though.
I know, right?
He's kind of charming.
I kind of want to let him steal.
Yeah, I kind of like him.
Yeah, maybe we can afford to let him steal a little bit.
Would you like...
Would you like a bag with those items?
Mua.
Yeah, he's not a doppelganger of anyone, I think.
He's just a little gnome.
Yeah, he's just...
I like his profile picture so much.
The ID photo is so funny.
I love him.
Can we just accept the trend?
Let's just accept the trend back.
Yeah, just let him go.
Bye-bye.
He paid?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
He paid!
Oh, he's just sliding away.
Oh, no.
Where is he going home to?
Whoa.
Where did he go?
He faded.
He faded out of existence.
Into the bush.
Oh, make it quick, bud.
I've got net business to deal with.
Net business.
I don't know what that means, but Ryan.
I want the hat.
No.
Okay.
Give me the hat.
That was on the hat.
You're being a bit rude.
rude ryan i have to say i think he's normal though you okay
yeah i'm gotchaing right now oh you're gotcha he's also
1967.
oh cat you oh hang on sorry sorry ryan hello yeah
Oh, my gosh, his photo.
Mr. Ryan.
Non-human eradication task force, Net.
We're the reason those doppelgangers haven't ripped you
apart yet.
You should be grateful.
Okay, buddy.
Oh, Net database.
Oh, so he's, so they're the guys that run the database.
Right, right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Man, I guess he's fine then.
Get out of here.
Rude.
I'm gonna keep doing more gotcha.
Oh, uh, ah!
Oh.
What was that?
You let two doppelgangers complete transactions earlier in
the night.
Two!
The entity has been alerted.
It will arrive in 60 seconds!
Oh, okay.
If he's 40 arbiter, then it was worth.
Uh, ah!
Uh, watch out.
I'm boarding it out.
Oh my god.
Where are you guys?
Vicky, get in here.
Get in here so we can board up the door.
Get in, get in, get in, guys!
Get in!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna put this bear trap down here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do we do?
Wait, there's another door.
There's another door over here.
There's another door.
We don't have enough.
Shoot.
Do we get the gun?
Get the gun?
Okay, I have a gun.
Wait, who wants the gun?
Emergency weapons arsenal.
Oh, we only have one gun?
We have one gun.
We will give it to me.
I'm not gonna be helpful.
Oh, you don't want the gun?
Okay.
No, you take the gun.
I'm getting in!
Oh God, I'm scared.
I'm trying.
He's gonna push us out.
It's coming.
Look, there's that much space.
It can hear our mics.
There's a mic.
Oh, he did.
Shoot!
Hold it.
No!
Yeah, shoot it, shoot it!
Oh
my god.
Where are you?
Are you guys still alive?
Yes.
I'm here!
Okay.
Keep running!
I hope Earth ends.
He likes ASMR.
Maybe he does.
Very quiet.
You can
run, you know?
You can run, you know?
What did you get?
Did you watch him?
This is the ultimate, the ultimate gacha.
Entity, entity gacha.
If you got two coins for it.
Oh, hat?
Earbows!
Earbows are so cute!
They're so cute!
Oh.
Oh, wait, I forgot to press.
Oh, cute.
I'll keep that.
the little guy hat on.
Oh, I didn't- Burger on his!
Oh, lol, so random.
I got my burger on.
One more.
The little lol is so fun.
Yes, I'm gonna definitely be the burger.
Hard hat!
Cute.
Wargur.
Wait, what thought?
I know we let go of the little guy, but what about...
What else did we let go of the mesh and head to the other
one?
the bus okay do we is there any mess we I don't think so
also I don't know if you guys saw but it said that with each
failed failed attempt they get stronger so they'll be
stronger next time we might have to kill the little gnome oh
no he was friend it was cute were you guys okay where were
you hiding everywhere I was just around the the bathroom
stalls by the way are really are they goaded wait they're
probably so nice yeah yeah yeah i'm coming this is this is
this is all reusable that's so nice all right i'm coming
okay well at least we get to find now yeah who did we like
who was it
Okay, but...
Oh.
That's alright, isn't it?
One day remains until Suki's next medicine kills too.
Aww.
Wait, did it say?
It didn't say.
Official warning.
I thought it would say.
Yeah, I thought so too.
45 years ago, the infamous serial killer known as the
dentist.
There was a thing about the dentist.
Roamed midnight town, killing victims by ripping their jaws
off.
Oh.
Ooh.
Whoa.
Government authorities confirm new reports of a tall,
emaciated figure matching that description of this same
serial killer that died 40 years ago.
Oh.
He was that tall?
Witnesses describe a slender, broken jaw.
Oh, sorry, not slender.
Sorry.
Wait, I was...
Witnesses describe.
Slender with grabbable hips.
What does that even mean?
I don't know.
I just projected what I saw.
Yeah, he's so slender, every guy.
The slack, broken jaw, white, bloody bandaged hands and
cracker skin.
Did he have cat ears?
He kind of looked like him, though.
It follows the same method of killing as the original
dentist, removing the victim's jaw from their skull.
Creepy.
That's not the guy we've been seeing outside.
it oh it might be do not hide do not speak and do not look
back run until your legs no longer obey you oh my god oh my
god okay it's crazy that we can't even speak sir should you
successfully flee contact your loved ones while you still
can whoa wowzers witnesses who managed to escape but are all
found dead no more than a week later.
Ew.
Not us, bro.
No.
We're strong.
We're so strong.
We just survived the entity.
We gotchaed in front of the entity.
We're strong.
Oh, Grace was a doppelganger.
She mentions that the West Bridge had an extreme speed
limit.
Oh, the West Bridge was close.
Oh, it was close.
Oh, sneaky.
You guys, we got to kill Norbert.
Okay, Norbert was.
He's not just a silly little dude.
We gotta kill him.
Wait, that means the oil guy was actually human.
Ew, what?
Normal.
Alright.
Okay, we gotta remember the things from the modus board.
I'm gonna search for coins so we can do more gotcha.
I guess reading is actually important.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm looking for coins.
Leave it to me.
Oh, this is just a rehash of what they were saying about...
Oh, what they were saying before.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, the guy.
Quote at $40.
Oh, that's quite big.
Oh, he's gone.
That wasn't the dentist, right?
The guy out there.
The guy out here, yeah.
There's also lots of meat around.
He's gone.
Yeah, he's gone.
Oh, wait.
Something just rolled up.
the ball.
Maybe he's around.
Little guy.
Oh, is it the flesh ball?
Yeah, a flesh ball just moved.
Oh.
It came from the left, so... Hmm.
He's out there, maybe.
Yeah, he wasn't that tall, right?
So I think we're okay.
So there's a spider web again.
Let's see.
I hope the spider web's gone still.
I hope it's... Oh, it is?
Nice.
Wait, so we can buy more weapons and stuff.
we should i feel like buying more weapons might be a good
plan just in case yeah oh this is the gate okay all right
oh who hasn't checked the notice board oh i haven't sorry
that's me oh that's serial killer back from the dead dun dun
all right oh what was that well what should what am i to do
with you.
I'm gonna take my home.
And take the gift.
You got a rat!
Oh!
Wait, you got a rat?
It's right here.
Yeah, now it's because of my problem.
Oh my god!
It's so cute!
I know it!
Oh my gosh, where did I find the little guy?
That was that gas station grind treatment.
I'm out here making moves while you're still stuck in the
rat race.
Rickatron 3,000.
Wait a second.
His eye looked kind of funky did it oh wait yeah no this guy
does not have a lazy eye exactly two packs of cookies don't
be jealous being honest looking this good as its downside
wait this guy doesn't have a lazy eye he's fake he's fake
wait hold on let me ask about the lazy eye my eyes what you
want to do an eye test his birthday i think is also wrong oh
no june 7th sorry no no it's this oh what's this rats oh but
his birthday is six seven we got we got an email from the
manager rats have started running rampant around the store
they negatively affect store ratings so please catch them
and throw them in the dumpster they're so cute or find any
other way i'm shooting him oh yeah i think the lazy eye
thing you didn't have one you didn't have one suspicious no
suspicious i agree suspicious too suspicious yes why do
people keep coming and not when there's like human meat on
the floor.
You again.
Look, something happened last night.
Oh, what happened, Ryan?
Oh, it's him.
Oh, wait, I think he's okay, right?
Unless he's like steak or something.
Yeah, the dentist on the news.
It was fast, strong.
Wiped out my whole squad in seconds.
How did you survive them?
But it left me alive, just stood there staring at me.
Just stay sharp, all right?
Pray you never see that thing.
Oh, I took the helmet off.
I was going to say, it looks kind of different.
Oh!
He is here!
Wait!
Oh, the guy?
I think it's...
No, no, no!
Wait, look, he left us coins in the shape of a heart!
Aww!
That's very sweet of you.
Should I go up to him?
Hi.
Wait, there's a heart?
Wait, what happens?
Would you like this rat?
Oh!
Don't look at it.
What, what, what, what happened?
He looks a little creepy, but...
I think he likes us.
Maybe you're a friend.
Hi.
Hello.
Oh, he's staring.
He's staring at me.
Wait, he's staring at me.
Oh, he's really staring at me.
Is he looking at you, Phoebe?
He's looking at me.
He's got a... Oh, he is?
Yeah.
I think he's alright.
Yeah, I think the net guy's guy's fine thanks for the money
pal just in case at some point he's definitely gonna
something's gonna happen yeah for sure now he's safe wait
did I shut the door oh my god a rat what is that noise I'm
sorry you little guy oh wait oh is that is that set yeah
just in case the got you might want to go around the front
yeah yeah i'll go around i did shut it right
okay excuse me oh it's your 30th birthday oh that's lovely
oh happy carra hastings i will check your date of birth just
grabbing some supplies for my 30th birthday no no no no no
no no carra is 23 It's not your birthday.
She doesn't know her own birthday.
Shoot her.
September 27, 63.
Wait, what?
No, yeah, definitely 1964.
Oh, yeah, she's confused.
Nah, nah, nah.
She very suspicious.
Oh.
Whoa!
I got her.
Yeah.
Take her out.
Also, I'm going to purchase some things.
Good plan.
Oh, I just hear a police...
Wait, what's happening?
Wait, did we kill somebody?
Oh, oh, wait.
That's the sound of the police.
Was that for you, bro?
Yeah, was that for you?
Explosive.
Um, ah, there's a second Phoebe Chan GB!
Ah!
What?
Look at the, look at the, wait, wait, Phoebe say something
only Phoebe would say.
Say something only Phoebe would say!
Ah!
Oh me.
Just picking something up on my sister.
Cafferan.
Oh my god.
There's a lot of blood around.
Phoebe, we gotta put you to work.
Oh yeah, I'll take care of it.
Yeah, yeah.
I am the catch up master.
Oh, oh, I've got an idea.
Delgado.
He's still there.
Do you think it's fine?
I'm scared.
I don't want to get job scared.
Just picking up something from my...
What is this?
I don't want to get job scared!
What's so weird?
Catherine Delgado deceased.
Hang on, hang on.
What was your sister's name, bro?
No, no, no!
His sister's dead!
The sister's dead!
Shoot him!
He says he's picking something up from his sister.
You can shoot him!
I mean, what if it's just like, in memory?
Oh, you think it could be?
Maybe.
To go put the...
Brave?
Eww!
Can I put him in the trash, no?
Who has the gun?
What did you do?
There was nastiness all over the stall!
Eww!
Yeah, I had to clean it up.
Wait, there's no gun?
Guys, who has the gun?
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, do it in here.
Take it, take it.
Excuse me, sir.
Here, here, here.
You just take it from the box.
Yeah, there you go.
Do not trust you.
Shoot him in the head.
L-M-B, left mouse button.
Your race will perish.
That's what he said.
Yeah, I think we know that you fake, bro.
Yeah, we know.
We know.
You're so fake.
Everyone just ignore all the stuff, all the free samples on
the ground.
Free samples.
Free samples, free samples.
Huh?
Oh, that's the real him, man.
Wait, it's the real him.
It's the real him.
Wait, that's crazy.
Oh.
Gotta be careful, man.
they're everywhere ever feel like someone's watching you
because they are oh oh i missed one sorry what's that is
that trash you're gonna talk about your dead sister no okay
yeah people have been littering in the store lately oh my
god they are they really are that's disgusting Yeah, how
could they?
How could they?
Maybe we need to explode litterers too.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think he's alright.
I've checked it.
Should be good.
Gumbos!
Explo-
Where'd that other person go who came in here?
There was someone else who came in here.
Oh, I think they left.
I think they left.
Oh, no, they're here.
They're here.
Oh, just kidding.
There you are.
our pets bet bill i don't know hi oh hello oh wait what what
kind of store oh my gosh language oh my goodness language
for real also thank you for the raid thank you thank you for
the raid thank you welcome in
check this out i think we should get rid of him just for the
rudeness i know inhuman rudeness in inhuman rudeness hey you
take that back you take that yeah tell it right now hey
mister clean and easy star I died to the dentist wait what
did this guy die to the dentist wait this guy no no he says
he's alive he says he's alive someone in my chat said no
yeah he's supposed to be alive Okay, I think he's fine.
He thought there was someone who died, but I don't think it
was Colin.
He said another name.
Oh, did he?
Oh?
He said someone was dead on the floor, but I don't think it
was Colin.
I think it was someone else.
I think I think Colin's alright.
Hey, oh, I'll let him go.
We need the money.
Can't wait to never see you or this place again.
Yeah, screw you, Colin!
I hope the dentist gets you.
Oh, damn.
No, that's our Molotov.
That's our Molotov.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, okay.
It came that way.
It's ready for use.
Okay, good.
Oh, we're done.
We're all done.
Beat up any mess and head to the bus.
That was a great day shift, guys.
It doesn't let us like... Oh, or can we...
Yeah, it doesn't like let us restock or anything after the
shift's over.
So...
Yeah, do it.
Secret gotcha.
Oh
More gotcha more gotcha more gotcha 10 bucks 10 bucks wait
what's our quota 40 dollars.
Okay, nice 40 Oh Nice making the dosh.
Okay, but what is this cobra cola for?
Oh Go to enemies in the traps.
Googly eyes!
Do they move?
Oh, we look just like the puppets.
Oh?
What was that?
Did someone break something?
Um...
I heard a noise.
Yeah, I did too.
Wait, did you hear...
Wait.
Huh.
That from outside?
Watch out.
Watch your step.
Do we want to know?
Do we just want to get on the bus and leave?
I almost walked right into her.
Wait, I'm going to...
go see if that guy's still there oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
he's still there did you see him yet oh hi he's like right
in he's like right in the back now yeah he like looks at you
he like left us um coins in a heart yeah i think he likes us
very friendly we'll just keep him around i guess he's our
pet now yeah little pet dear chica
She's looking a little different these days.
Yeah, a little bit.
Yeah, if we can't keep Norbert, I think we can keep this
guy.
Yeah, I think it's fine.
All right.
All right, shift over.
Yeah.
Good job, you guys.
Good job, team.
Amazing day.
Beep, beep.
We did rather well.
I think so, too.
Yeah, yeah.
That was a perfect day, huh?
store revenue 90 we got paid 19 okay heck yeah bill is
coming the mail i'm gonna pay the bill me too you pay the
bill and the medicine arrives soon after you lose 40 dollars
but you see oh hubbeth hubbeth has the strength to join your
next Oh my god, wait!
Wait, what?
Yeah!
Doppelganger, doppelganger.
Perfect night, you guys!
Good job, good job!
Oh, we got all of the doppelgangers.
Oh, we're so good.
We're so good.
I like Tommy and Tommy.
Nice.
Oh my god!
I love Herbert and Goose.
Wait, where are you?
Ah, Tuki!
Wait, where are you going?
Please let us pet them.
Oh, my goose!
I goose.
Oh, he's so cute.
You're my little goose.
Aw, you're my little goose.
Aw.
He's been a little different.
I thought it would let us let us pet them though I'm feeling
a little hmm it would be a perfect game if we could yeah do
you think we can get like oh my god do you think we can get
like like hats and bows for them and stuff wait that'd be so
cute oh my god oh there's so many coins out here if you
haven't implemented that yet is she gonna oh he's our friend
there oh oh dude I think That's Ryan.
That.
That's the dentist.
Ryan and the dentist.
That's Ryan?
That's Ryan and the dentist.
Oh, damn.
Hey, Ryan.
Good job.
You're being so brave at the dentist.
You're going to get...
Is that Ryan the guy who's rude to us?
No, it's Ryan, isn't it?
Oh.
Well, Ryan was a little rude to us.
Just a little bit, but...
I was kind of like he was growing on me.
Yeah, I was still rooting for him.
him i think yeah the other guy though he he could easily
yeah other guy was ducky yeah have a have a good dentist
appointment ryan he was rude to us and also mean about to
ryan yeah that's true good news some contractors came and
finally boost the dashboard it's a little scary along with
your current duties now you must also help drivers by
pumping gas actually you must also detect if cars are
doppelgangers.
Read the note by the pump for further instruction.
Their cars?
Wait, their cars are... Does that mean that they can be
normal, but their cars might be doppelgangers?
Oh, my gosh.
What?
Lightning McQueen might be a doppelganger.
Herbert and Goose are buddies.
They are, yeah.
They keep walking around together.
I think actually Lightning McQueen would be a doppelganger.
Yeah, right?
Have you seen the inside of Lightning McQueen?
Yeah.
I don't know if I've seen the inside of Lightning.
I watched Cars for the first time recently, and that movie
terrified me a little bit.
For the first time?
Yeah, yeah.
Whoa!
That's kind of exciting.
It was!
It was so fun and also terrifying.
Yeah, I know you mean, it could be a horror movie.
It could be.
Ew.
Oh!
Gas mask.
I don't think I'm good.
I'm psychomantis!
I wonder if the ranking was...
for our combini will improve now we have animals i'm sure it
will get rid of that horrid number we got yeah there we go
i'm supporting doppelganger cars ask driver how you can help
use the flashlight to search the car for suspicious item
unicorn unicorn hat
oh you guys are you guys are doing the tutorial do you open
fire on the car or on the person ask the driver how you can
help use the flashlight okay okay to search versus ignore
normal oh ignore normal wait you got the hat yeah i'm a good
boy amazing incredible oh oh okay oh what oh oh oh oh here's
our flashlight i got it oh hello how are you give me 13 of
gas and make it snappy you understand i'm using the car to
search oh what's this doppelgangers continue to ravage
america throughout the night we can ask about the
doppelganger oh the world's gone to sheesh oh i think it's
fine though oh it says it said ignore normal crimes right
yeah i think this is actually pretty normal given the
circumstances of everything on the registry device oh zero
four zero four lj
our animals are running rampant it's so great oh register
wait where is the registry device not blue station wagon
dirt marks oh oh it's here it's here oh okay what was it
zero oh four lj zero four lj dirt's on lower exterior
registration expiring next year it looks good to me i'm
gonna fill him up yeah dirt marks on blue station wagon dirt
marks on lower area oh here pick up yeah oh stand back
further oh oh oh sorry i'm missing a little bit sorry sir oh
sorry sir oh dear oh sorry yeah so sorry i think they're all
right i think so too We aren't meant to- Oh, hello.
Wait, how do I say- Oh, you're good- Oh.
Tell him he's good to leave.
How do we say he's good to go?
You talk to him.
Ah.
Bye-bye.
Gotta hitch a ride.
Bye!
That person just come in and- Goose, stay away from the
fire.
I don't want any chicken today.
Does he have eyes?
Hey, buddy.
Look at you working hard.
I'd love that energy Does he have eyes?
Oh, I'm not quite sure.
Both eyes are duds, but that just means I've got a fresh
perspective.
Oh, maybe he's, maybe it's just...
His name is Danny Boy.
That's just the way he is.
Danny Boy.
Wait, he's blind in his left eye, but he has both eyes right
now.
Oh.
Yes, sir.
Both eyes are duds, but that just means I got a fresh
perspective.
Oh, whoa.
Get rid of him, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It's suspicious.
It should only be left eye.
Yeah.
Oh, rat.
No, don't eat that meat!
Oh, God!
Did I eat it?
What happened?
Oh, don't worry.
Suki, Suki absolutely did not eat the human meat.
Don't worry about it.
No, don't worry about it.
Fine, don't worry.
Barry Alki.
Has some dirt under his fingernail.
Why did they put that in, like, the description?
You ever wonder what they would put in yours?
Oh, you...
Who did this?
Sure.
Guys, don't come in the bathroom right now.
Oh, hang on, guys.
What?
I met this wizard and he gave me some magic beans.
I sculpt them last night this morning.
I woke up two feet tall and magic is wild.
Hang on.
Wait, what?
That sounds very suspicious.
It says he's short.
Oh, goose.
Oh, no, man.
Weird question to ask.
And he also doesn't really have dirt.
I guess I do.
I'm always working on something.
Hard to avoid it.
Shoot him.
Kill him.
I think let's do it.
Where's the gun?
Take it.
Oh.
Go, man.
Oh!
Go man.
Do not- Oh!
Both are- oh, they're all eating- Oh!
No!
Gross!
God no!
No!
Herbert, stop that right now!
Cookie!
That's quite useful though, in a way.
Are- Yeah, right, actually.
It's on the walls in the bathroom.
Are our animals doppelgangers?
What?
Oh, yeah.
Our- Oh.
Buenas naches, amigo!
Don't mind me, these people!
Stop moving, baby!
Oh, oh yes!
Wow, oh yeah!
I love Esteban!
The rhythm's in my head, amigo.
Look at his ID, look at his signature.
He's very short.
Oh, he's got a...
He's so real, he's the most real out of everybody.
Very short.
Bald spots shining, but the brain still remembers every
stuff!
Me.
I love him.
I love him too.
I think he's good.
I love him so much.
No!
Oh, he's moonwalking out!
Guys, I'm sorry.
Mosh, mosh.
Mine telling me why...
A buttload of reds are pouring out of the bathroom!
Oh, um...
Get to work!
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, I feel bad for the little rats.
Or the dogs taking care of it too?
Hey!
Yeah, I don't think we can do anything without a gun.
Oh, really?
Sorry.
You want to try?
You can toss them!
You can toss them.
Also, also, uh, what's his face is outside with a lemonade?
Yeah, I was gonna get him.
I was actually on my way to get him and then this...
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh, you can toss them, sorry.
Yeah, you can toss them.
Oh, yeah.
How many more are there?
Oh, my God, there's so many more.
Oh, my God.
That's so many!
Oh, we did it!
Yeah!
I think so.
Oh, no.
Wait, there's still more, though.
I guess we just have to have a 100% success rate.
Hey.
Um, Norbert?
I have decided to sell lemonade.
Would you like some?
Actually, I would like some.
I'll try some.
I promise I won't put you...
Wait, should we buy it?
Look, if one of us tries it, we can just see what happens,
right?
Here we go.
I'm drinking it.
We're drinking it.
Was it delicious?
Oh.
Nothing's happening, I think.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Wait, maybe don't drip.
Whoa, whoa.
Ouch!
Oh no!
What can we...
Ouch!
What is the dance?
Oh.
What can we do?
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
I'm fine now.
Oh, are you good now?
Yeah, I'm okay now.
Oh, good job.
Good job, team.
Give it a little.
Oh.
Oh, are we going to finally kill him?
I killed him.
His dad is still there.
Yeah, I think he got her.
I'm going to drink the regular.
Oh, man, I can't.
Hello, mister.
Ninety-eighths.
Oh.
Um.
Uh.
Do you?
Oh.
I think that looks suspicious, doesn't it?
That looks quite suspicious, I'd say.
Hmm.
We're going to get a lot of killing tonight, huh?
little rundown bits my baby you enjoy all the killing
oh I think the car is dead oh there it goes oh my god oh my
god wait I want to see what he says about this this is so
impressive holy well he is very very talented I am I am
mesmerized I need to know oh Call me!
He left his phone over!
Oh my god!
He said, I'm not listening to a thing you're saying, just
admiring the way your tender lips move.
Oh my god.
So safe.
What's cooking?
Call me!
Rudnick.
We can look him up in the database, the Rudnick.
Is that his name?
Oh, Rudnick, you're right.
Rudnick West.
Deceased.
Cause of dead mutilation.
Oh, I don't want to kill him though, but I think we might
have.
I think I want to kill him.
Please kill him.
Ooh, mailbox.
But I will bag his products first.
Why don't we place anywhere?
Oh, 22 decor points.
Landmine.
Do I kill him?
I'll grab it.
Yeah, kill him.
Do I kill him?
Arrg, he says.
Oh, feast my animals.
They are insatiable.
They are so hungry.
Feast.
Look how they're running off of that.
I know they've never eaten them their entire lives.
I'll go grab them.
Oh, actually, that's a...
I'm going to restock stuff.
Yeah.
Oh, we got to restock.
Oh, shoot.
I'm grabbing some products.
Oh, oh.
Good evening.
Uneventful night, I hope.
Wait, is she dripping blood?
Wait, where's...
Oh, she is missing a hand!
And is dripping...
Does she need a pat?
Oh, no.
She is missing a hand.
Oh, I'm stuck in it.
Just...
Um...
Oh.
I mean, that might not mean that she's not human.
It doesn't say that she...
Are you okay?
Ma'am?
Limbs.
But there's also, like, blood on her.
I was born missing this hand.
I'm beautiful in my way.
I just miss in the hand.
I'm on the right track.
Baby born without a hand.
Mosque?
You just...
I'm shooting her.
She's making a mess.
Yeah, that sounds very suspicious.
Thank you for the super chat.
I think you need to hold Mint back from killing everything
that moves well she's not killing everything no i'm not i'm
just killing all the things that matter hello oh it's the
sheriff oh nice to see you again sheriff he's like a comfort
character he is like delivery has wrong i am back how's the
job working out for you well you're still alive so you're
doing better than most i'm proud of you kid not many are
willing to take a job this dangerous your job is as
dangerous as mine but you don't get the same respect i do
klyne you've got my respect if it means anything can we give
it to i don't want anything bad to happen to klyne me
neither i like him a lot i do too great guy he looks good to
me you're good to go mister you're good to go thanks for
always looking out for us klyne oh shift done oh we can
restock oh yeah do you see poop on the on the walls oh yeah
there's the people here are disgusting okay my actual
question though is like have you ever been to a public
bathroom and seen like poop on the walls or people poop on
the ceiling or something like i have yeah how does it get
like that who knows what is this did you see the video of
the guy that got stuck in a like underneath the porta potty
what how the fire department had to come and use like a a
chainsaw or something to like cut open the porta potty and
get him out oh my gosh how did you get in there sir how'd
you get in there so bad those things swell be awful yeah
right wait i also ordered a bat did anyone see it a bat oh a
bat yeah i ordered a A bat with nails.
There's blood out here.
It's probably not a good look.
Oh, I got it.
I'll get it for you.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, your shift is gone.
Where's our bat?
Oh, it's on the wall.
Oh, yeah, it is.
Wait, it's so cool.
Oh, wow.
He got stuck in the porta potty because he wanted to get his
Mountain Dew bottle.
Is that real?
I want some more of that lemonade.
If you know what I mean.
How was it?
Should I try some?
Can you?
Also, Norbert's liquids.
Did Norbert just pee in it?
I just drank some.
Wait.
Mmm.
It was called Norbert's Liquids?
Oh.
Oh, man.
Oh, oh, what's happening?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, God.
What's happening?
You guys.
Oh, wow.
I'm feeling something.
Oh, oh.
Oh, you're like hugging yourself.
Why are you dancing?
Let's go on the bus.
Oh, wow.
I'm gonna go do a gotcha real quick.
Oh, yeah.
Come here.
Oh,
coolest guy ever.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, a tank!
Oh, wait, oh, my gosh.
Wait, that's perfect.
Yeah, wait, that's perfect.
My gosh, that's so perfect.
Oh, my God, it looks so good.
Scare off the entity with this one.
Yeah.
Ten bucks!
Yippee!
Okay, 45.
Hat.
A crown.
Oh.
So cute.
I know, they're so cute.
Where'd the geese go?
Okay, that's goose.
Where's Herbert?
Goose!
Herbert?
I see.
Oh, yeah, I see him.
Herbert's got places to be.
Oh my gosh.
Goose is just a chilling guy.
Never mind.
Shall we go?
and the ship end yeah we're good i felt like a good guy to
me i thought we killed most people though so i wonder yeah
we didn't make much money i think because we killed a lot of
people oops did we reach our quota i think yeah we did we
did we reached the quota right thank you for the super chat
i have survival instincts i do
let's see then how many we got right yeah oh i assume thanks
for clearing out those rats in time oh sorry only 20 right
only 20 two days remain until goose is next why is the
medicine so expensive and so quick i know right dead
customers tended under tip no look we killed all dog look i
was
We did it!
Wow, thank you.
Oh, yeah.
I like the Rodney one.
Esteban and Clyde are Oshis.
Yeah, I love Esteban.
He contorted in impossible ways when entering the store.
That wasn't the bit that concerned me, actually.
I know, right?
She's missing a hand.
She was said that she was born that way, but it's always
bleeding.
Yeah, it's a little concerning.
She could have also been born that way.
I'm beautiful in my way.
oh um oh this looks good oh it's a go check outside for the
what's his face the dentist the dentist maybe yeah that kind
of day the dentist is gonna be hanging out doesn't it that's
that him yeah yeah is nookotan still around i miss that i
miss that guy
check in for all of the money so we can do more gacha oh
surprisingly not a lot happening oh what have you seen oh
check the break room the break room the break room oh my god
oh hello is he moving hi is he asleep is that not the
dentist isn't that the dentist right yeah I think so look
what if we just Put it right at the bottom.
Yeah.
Nice idea.
Is there anything out here then?
Nothing out here?
Nothing out there?
I don't see it.
You might be wondering what the thing in the break room is.
Don't worry, it's just a corpse.
A local mystic told me that displaying it will help war dog
doppelgangers.
Oh.
Just try to forget it's there.
Okay.
Okay Okay, okay, sure.
I wonder if these please go for some gacha More gotcha more
gotcha.
Did our did our pets come with us today or no?
Oh, I didn't see them.
No, I missed them.
Yeah, I didn't see them actually
Phoebe It's perfect for you.
It's perfect New hat new main hat.
I made flower in here.
Nice.
Oh, we have something in the shop.
Somebody in the shop?
Anything interesting to get.
Oh, hello.
Urgent blood moon tonight.
What does that mean?
Oh, no.
A blood moon signifies.
What is it?
Oh, wait, what is it?
What?
The entity will come tonight, no matter what.
No!
Apparently.
Oh.
Oh, leading transactions with doppelgangers will trigger
even stronger assault.
Let's order things.
Let's order planks and order shotgun.
We can order a shotgun.
Shotgun.
Yes, yes, yes.
A backpack.
Oh.
Before I get started with anything, I'm going to run to the
bathroom.
Okay.
Minto.
Yes.
She says she works all night, right?
she's night at the bar and then she says I'm exhausted been
at work since the morning oh make sense to you no no it
doesn't right unless she meant like early in the morning I'm
very confused by time zone yeah let's ask her let's ask her
yeah the bars only open at night means I'm a night owl same
as you I think I think but then why would you say been at
work since the morning killer killer heal her!
Shoot!
Yeah, I'm gonna, I don't know, it sounds suspicious It
sounds too suspicious, yeah.
Get her in the head.
Nice.
Yeah.
That's right.
That's right, that's right.
Yeah.
Wait, where's our shotgun?
Where's me?
Oh, hello.
Hello there.
Oh, are you okay?
Oh dear.
Are they okay?
Oh, are you okay, Beth?
Oh, Beth!
Hold on.
Oh, dear, Beth.
Oh, Beth.
Um, maybe.
What does she say about that, actually?
I'm just curious.
Um, she's just, she's just sort of brushing it off,
basically.
It's a little scarred.
I think it's a bit more than a little bit.
Oh, yeah.
Beth Callahan?
It says she's alive.
Scar on her left cheek.
I think it's...
got a little worse yeah it's a little fresh lady we shoot
enough yep language Beth language oh my goodness oh I have
to take both of these to the garbage I messed up my
inventory is all garbage thanks for the rain you look tired
would you like a candy oh oh yes I would what kind of candy
we talking lady I would say I look rather young for my age
yes Agnes oh it says she was born in three years ago see
Agnes yeah yeah maybe we have to balance like maybe it's all
gonna be doppelgangers if we keep We're not going to get any
money.
We're not going to make any money.
Yeah.
Maybe we have to like balance it out.
I don't know.
How are we supposed to make money?
Like we should get money from shooting doppelgangers, no?
Yeah.
I feel like we should at least.
Sorry if I'm a bit out of it.
Got off.
A late shift rebuilding a carburetor.
Okay.
Didn't ask.
No, I'm just kidding.
But she's a computer engineer.
What's a carburetor?
Isn't that for a car?
What?
I'm an engineer.
carburetors engines exhaust systems the works that's not an
engineer i think she's like i'm an engineer like i wait
that's so funny like she's she works on engines yeah maybe
maybe she doesn't understand wait that's three doppelgangers
i think i think she's suspicious don't you think
Wait, hold on.
Watch this.
Oh, great.
Yes, maybe that's what we need to do.
Just make sure to do it in the right order.
I like your thinking, Minto.
I like your thinking.
You take their money and then you kill them.
What are they going to do with it?
Yeah.
Oh, there's a car.
Oh, wow.
Mint, look at this ride.
Whoa.
Wow.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
Phoebe, come look at this car.
Thank you.
What happened?
Oh, what a cool car.
Whoa.
Sup, champ.
Oh, I'm a champ.
Oh, he's got lots of balls.
Why is he got so many balls in his back?
Apparently the lights and flames does exist.
Eight victims of the calendar killer.
After an extensive search, bodies of the eight individuals
reported missing in October with the calendar killer have
been discovered beneath West Bridge.
Authorities continue to search for those who disappeared in
November.
Wait, what?
Wait, what's the calendar killer?
Yeah, I think he's all right, actually.
I think he's okay.
I was using it to wipe my shoes.
I mean, it does, it does, it does show.
It does have a footprint on it, right?
Yeah, it does have a footprint on it.
I wonder what is the calendar killer is.
Yeah, I think he's fine, maybe.
I think, yeah, he seems to be our call.
I'm gonna restock while we can.
I'm restocking, I'm restocking.
You may leave, you may leave.
And may I say lovely car.
Yeah, he's got a great car.
Yeah.
Hello?
Moshy moosh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, what happened?
Oh.
Bad news.
Managers call, the rain's messing with the mechanism that
opens the door.
The emergency weapons are small.
Oh.
Come on.
That creepy painting.
Wait, what do you mean painting?
Painting.
Painting?
Oh, no.
Oh.
So it wasn't the...
Oh, come on, man.
Hello?
Are we going to have to deal with both the dentist and the
entity tonight?
Why did he write?
Oh, we got wallatops and we got explosives.
I think we got this.
Wait, what else is there in the shop?
Oh, I bought it all.
Um, hello.
All right, good be rude.
Lino Rowe.
Oh, my God, you guys.
He's gone.
He's just gone.
We might need to get some more stock boxes for products.
Oh, yeah, I think so, too.
Oh, oh my god.
I'm watching it.
Lady!
What?
I just watched her poop all over the walls!
She was waiting for you to watch.
She really did.
She didn't shut the door or anything.
She just started going.
Ew!
Oh, it is a painting now.
It is a painting.
Oh.
Creamy.
baby she ate the lettuce you guys i think she's all right i
think she's all right i'm gonna let her go okay i trust
do you think it's the dentist basket rack oh i don't want to
deal with the dentist backpack extra inventory slot for all
employees i don't think we really need an extra slot
currently yeah i think we're okay Oh, yeah, we hit our
quota.
We hit our quota.
We're doing great
Yeah Give me a cosmetic Please
Pretty please Oh, you are a computer engineer.
Ushanka.
Oh, sorry.
I pointed out her acne.
Whoops.
Well, thanks for cleaning out the poop, guys.
Of course.
I know.
It just happened in front of my face.
I can't believe it.
Yeah, this seems quite normal.
You're very normal.
Birthday, okay?
Yeah.
Computer engineer.
okay what didn't we see oh yeah this is the real one oh yeah
oh yeah I think so okay I'll let her go what is that bye-bye
go check the bathroom check bro stop boobin oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh start hide go hide start start boarding things up
Oh, here I'll grab the...
I'll get it on the other one.
Come on.
Oh, you got it?
Okay.
Leave the trap here.
There's no other doors.
This trap we should be boarding up.
Yeah, yeah.
The door...
Pick up a Molotov?
This, like that.
Oh no, wait.
I can't throw away my garbage.
I can't pick up anything else.
Grab...
What is this?
What is this path?
Someone grab the gun!
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
I can't grab it, unfortunately.
Grab it.
Okay, nice, Phoebe, it's all on you, it's all on you.
Oh, God.
Let's go to the bathroom.
Let's go hide in the bathroom, yeah.
Yeah, the bathroom is good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Grab a stall, grab a stall.
And then close the door behind you too.
Oh, oops.
I'm really bad at closing doors.
Oh, God, I just closed the bathroom door.
Oh my gosh.
Yes, Phoebe.
I got a gun too.
It's doing great.
It's doing great, guys.
Please.
Yay.
How do I revive me?
Help me.
Oh, hi.
Oh, no.
There's a, there's med packs in the back.
There's med packs in the bag.
Oh, we're med packs.
This thing.
Wait, why weren't they picking it up?
Help.
Help!
I can still...
Wait, it won't let me pick anything up anymore.
Help!
Is your inventory full?
No, I just have one flashlight in it.
Oh.
Like a cat.
Uh-oh.
Like cat.
Help!
Oh, shoot.
I can't even do the...
Oh, no.
I can't even do the gotcha anymore.
I wonder if it's bugged.
Wait!
Oh, wait, I can do it!
I can heal.
You can do it.
Okay.
Wait, oh.
Baby, we're kind of like nearly dead.
Can you don't do the gacha right now?
I'm spamming E.
I can't do anything.
Is it hold?
Hold E?
Hold E.
It won't even let me do the gacha currently.
I can't activate anything.
Wait, let's- Oh, I think it's because our shift is done.
Let's go to the- Let's go to the bus and say- Let's just go
to the bus.
Let's just go to the bus.
We're coming.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
We'll be right there.
Yeah, we're right there.
Wait, guys, I can't even get on the bus.
I can't get on the bus.
Wait.
Uh...
We'll be right there.
Oh wait, no.
Oh, Phoebe!
Right!
Phoebe, run to the real bus!
Just run to the real bus!
The real bus!
Oh,
thank goodness.
Thank goodness.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
We're fine.
Everything's fine, you guys.
We're good, guys.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Yeah, what a twist.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know why it glitched.
I had to go into my menu and then come back out of the menu.
No, that's okay.
We made it somehow.
Holy cow.
Holy moly.
Yeah, we got those doppelgangers.
Oh, perfect.
you guys let's go nice job yeah the the bar that only opens
at night but have been working since the morning you trusted
your intuition oh trust the intuition baby that must have
been what happened when i was in the bathroom oh oh yeah
maybe maybe i'm grabbing wait so who chased you was that the
dentist who was that they look they look very tall so yeah
probably it was the dentist there There's a blood on the
ceiling.
Oh.
Yeah, there's a ceiling.
Oh, wow.
Hmm.
Oh, is this just from last night?
Oh, it might have been.
It's the emotescope.
It reads customer emotions and allows you to question them
on their emotions.
It is 100% accurate, but take note.
Some dockable gangers are able to replicate human emotions
and some can't.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, this thing.
Oh, this equipment is stupidly expensive to rent.
You'll only get the device on occasional days oh okay okay
interesting we're shut for some reason did you clean the
stuff i cleaned some blood in the bathroom okay i'll grab
need to i'm gonna bin up i'm gonna bin up the meat oh i got
the meat it's okay okay yeah oh oh i'm so sorry somebody
There's a mess in there, though.
Hard night.
Hard night, yeah.
I'm just sorry.
I'll grab it.
Game is stressful, but it's so fun.
Yeah, it's a little.
It's a little...
We're saving Densetsu, you guys!
Yeah!
No-kotan?
Shika
no-kon-on-on-on-on-kotan-on-on-on-on-on-on-on-on-on-on-on-on-on-on.
No, she's not.
I'm looking.
She hasn't been here in a while, actually.
Yeah, I've been looking.
I miss, I miss Chikunoko.
Yeah, I miss her too.
Wait, there's still blood on the ceiling.
How do we get that?
How do we...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, you got it.
Oh, cool.
I thought I picked that up this way.
Okay.
I just got jump scared by a different way.
Oh, I have to read the note!
Sorry!
Uh, Vicky, if you haven't read the note yet.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, I need to read the note.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, why isn't the computer on?
Read the note?
Oh, on the counter.
Yeah, it's on the counter.
On the counter.
So what does it do?
Oh, I can scan.
The emotion stuff.
Yeah.
What's this?
Oh yeah.
I can scan you guys.
Oh, really?
What does it say?
You're feeling aroused.
Why are you feeling aroused?
Yeah, it says you're feeling aroused.
You know why Phoebe Chan-Chi means.
Whoa!
Do I?
Do I know what?
What?
Mid-Fantone.
Travis.
How much?
You are feeling aroused.
What?
Why are you feeling aroused?
It says you're busy.
I can't ask you why you're aroused.
Oh, I think you know Phoebe Chan-Chi-Chii.
What?
Wait, it says there's a new creature spotted around the
entity.
Oh, no.
Oh, these creatures are only vulnerable to damage when not
being observed.
So, what?
It's extremely fast and strong, but looking at it will
freeze it in place.
While frozen, it is completely invincible.
Traps must be set up in advance to deal with this creature.
Oh, I don't like that.
green light type thing yes yes i don't like that i don't
like that yeah it's a weeping angel is this guy good travis
i think i think he's all right i haven't asked him strong
stench but i think he's all right i've been working on my
car and sometimes sleeping in it too oh i think he's just a
bit smelly but i think he's all right missing all his teeth
speaks with a noticeable lisp wait he has teeth somehow
married wait hold on does he oh i didn't notice the teeth
there he has teeth
i think he i think he has teeth let me have a little look he
says he doesn't have any but he's got teeth he's got teeth
yeah shoot him shoot him shoot him he's definitely got teeth
my brother-in-law looks over the net database dude hates me
oh yeah so it's like completely Do it.
Oh.
Are you ready?
Yeah, go for it.
Shoot his teeth.
Oh.
Okay.
Do it open and leave it?
La la la la la.
Oh.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, wait.
I guess we could have done his mood.
He was content and calm.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wow, at least just putting their trash everywhere.
I'm just after some supplies for the beach Might as well
enjoy it now while it's still nice warm and sunny.
It's not it's
What's up It glitched I was meant to get ten dollars and it
didn't give it to me No way Scam scam scam scam scam Hello,
what is that surprising to you?
How many, how many one?
Wait, how many, how many?
Where's the mood scanner?
Where did it go?
Uh, yeah, oh, I think you can just grab it here.
I got it.
Oh, F to scan.
She is warm.
The sun's blazing out there.
Wow, I mean, that would make sense considering, um, just out
with, you know.
Wait, she keeps talking about the sun, but it's nighttime.
I think, I think she's gotta die.
Yeah, I think probably.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
She does have seven piercings.
I guess?
Maybe?
Is she saying it's sunny right now or she just feels hot?
Because some people, you know, they're saying hot.
She's pretty sure.
I'm headed to the beach.
At night?
You're headed to the...
I'm talking about how she wants to go to the beach.
No, she says she's going to...
But she says I might as well soak up the sun while I can.
Oh, that is suspicious.
That is suspicious.
Sorry, you're hot, but you kind of got...
Yeah, I think you got...
Don't objectify me.
Oh, do it, Phoebe.
You won't be objectified ever again.
Remember to purchase traps on the computer to survive the...
Okay.
Oh, oh, we have two cars.
Wait, what's happening?
Wait, what's going on?
What is happening?
Bro is, like, blocked.
Oh, it's Norbert!
Norbert, come on, man.
Norbert!
I'm here!
What's he got in his...
He's got a nice little...
He's got a nice little ride.
I'm getting in.
Have you guys read his emotions or whatever?
Oh, no, I haven't.
Oh, yeah, where's the emotion thing?
car.
No.
Marvart.
Did you kill him?
What's your mood, Norbert?
This person is feeling wah!
Is feeling what?
He's feeling wah!
Wah!
Oh, Norbert.
I love him.
Wait, oh my god, that girl behind you is so...
as much as we love you oh my god this this guy who keeps
walking into norbert though i'm afraid of shooting the
civilian oh god you could shoot from the other side no oh
yeah i'll shoot from yeah yeah i'll shoot from here we
believe in you uh oh guys there's so many people walking
into the car oh there we go whoa okay nice nice yeah nice
but we actually have another car we do have car actually is.
Oh, hi buddy, look at you, working hard.
Love that energy.
Oh, this is the guy.
He's real, though, maybe.
Daniel.
Danny boy.
I miss Norbert, too.
Always smiling, blind and left eye.
Yeah.
Left eye's a dud, but that just means I got a fresh person.
He says the same thing as the doppelganger, too.
I think this guy's real, them.
Oh yeah, this one does look real.
Oh, wait, we're back.
Real window cranks, yeah, so that's all...
I'm scanning him.
He's cheerful and optimistic.
Why are you...
Oh, wait, that's fine.
I believe him.
I think he's real.
Come on, give you your gas.
Yeah, it's the real one this time.
Let's buy some...
Let's see.
I don't think we need more planks, do I?
Anything else?
Oh, should I...
Should I analyze his emotions as well?
end up here
yeah what is he feeling tired it's past midnight of course
i'm tired yeah i think he's good to go i think he's good to
go wait did you check the back of his car and stuff yeah it
was all right it all checked out normal guy good wait how do
we send how do we send off the cars i never know mayor
dawson spends night in storm Mayor Dawson waited through
floodwaters to carry stranded children to safety and stayed
until every family was accounted for.
Quietly insisting anyone would have done the same.
Wait, that guy looks like the dentist!
Ah!
Hey!
Wait, where's this?
Where are you finding this?
That was in that guy's car.
Oh.
Yeah, you have to...
Sometimes the flashlight will show hidden stuff.
Hello, darling.
Hi.
You're feeling craving human flesh.
Ask why.
Craving.
That's an ugly way to put it.
I'd say appreciating the texture.
You know what?
I've sometimes appreciated the texture of humans, especially
when you're giving them big hugs.
So...
11 years making people look their best.
Maybe that's why she craves the human flesh.
Yeah, maybe.
I think I'm going to kill her.
Just a little solved.
Yeah, I think we probably got to get rid of her.
yeah i mean she could just be a cannibal and not you know i
am cannibal that is true oh there's some on the phoebe if
you want to get the blood on the the counter oh yes thank
you
yes yes i'm cleaning up all this garbage people are leaving
my goodness
he's at the counter
party parts out there.
We are.
Darlah.
She's got a Vatilagal.
She's an Olympic swimmer.
Vatilagal.
Oh, Olympic swimmer.
Pretty cool.
You can see it.
Show us some swimming right now.
Yeah, show us some swimming.
How are you feeling, Darlah?
Come on.
Exhaust.
ask why been training all day you know I can believe that
yeah oh no no no no no she's fake she's fake she's fake
she's fake she's fake she said they took the photo yesterday
but it says details updated weekly oh oh wait what what's
wrong with the photo if you ask about her photo she's like
yeah they took that they took that yesterday oh wait what if
they updated them yesterday okay now What if the other one?
Well, I mean, you're being very careful.
I was really careful.
No.
That's okay.
I thought I was on to something.
Nah, you were good.
You were good.
No, you were being very careful.
I was having my Benedict Cumberbatch Sherlock moment.
Oh, no.
Oh, hello.
Oh.
What's up?
Wake up, Dimwit.
It's the man above.
No one is calling.
Boss, I mean.
Not God.
Customers have been complaining about some stink coming from
the woods behind the store.
Oh, God.
Oh, yeah.
I figured it was a dead raccoon, but nope, limbs.
Oh, yeah, I was just talking about a hecton of limbs
scattered throughout the forest.
So you're going out there.
Grab the limbs, toss them, burn them, whatever.
Just make the smell stop.
One more thing.
I think I saw something roaming around the forest.
Looks like it didn't want me to see it.
Oh, my God.
It's probably nothing.
Jeez.
You're pooping on the walls, pooping on the ceiling.
Head to the forest behind the store.
Head to the forest.
Do we want to take, like, any weapons?
Yeah.
I got the gun.
Yeah, take the bat.
Take the bat.
I want to take the bat.
Hey.
Okay.
I will grab a...
I will grab a mop.
Yeah.
What's back here?
I'll take out some of the trash from there.
How do we...
Do we just jump the fence?
How do we get in there?
Enter the forest behind the store.
Yeah, how do we get out here?
How do we get out?
Uh...
Oh, here, here, here.
Oh, ooh, it's creepy.
Oh, I'll have the flashlight for you.
Bring a trash bag.
Oh, I'll bring a trash bag.
Trash bag, trash bag.
Okay, I'll bring one too, just in case, yeah.
Oh, does someone have a flashlight?
Okay, cool.
It's scary.
Because I can't see a blooming thing.
Wait, this is so scary.
Oh, okay, you guys, don't run too far off from each other.
Okay, yeah.
but we gotta oh what was that anything else are we good now
no we need out of 15 three out of 15 yeah oh god i saw some
more over here let's go oh there's something in the bushes
here well hey watch out yeah uh i don't see a blue yeah
we're gonna need you phoebe to guide us oh what is that yeah
no problem uh let's go this way it's no but's juice Ew.
Oh, here's some, here's some.
Lots more over here.
Oh, I can't, oh, I can't see it.
I cannot freaking see.
Oh, yeah, Phoebe, if I drop this trash bag.
No, you can't drop it.
Let's take trash to them.
Yeah, it's okay.
I have a trash bag, too.
I think Vicky does too, yeah.
Okay, I also have one.
Did we get all of them?
This way, then.
Oh, okay.
So much.
Oh, there's one here.
There's one there.
Whoa, what does that sound?
Hope it's safe.
Hey.
Okay.
This is scary.
I know, right?
How are we going to get back?
I'm lost.
How many more do we need?
Like, six more?
Another six more.
There's a lot.
Don't say there.
Do the math.
Wait, I know there's some over here by the dumpster.
I remember seeing them from the fence.
Yeah, oh here.
Oh yeah, you're right here.
Whoa, what was that?
Lightning.
Thunder.
Oh, that's just, it's just thunder.
Yeah.
Lightning and the thunder.
You don't think it's Nookotan, right?
Nookotan is friendly.
Over here.
This is back to where we were.
Yeah.
But we're almost done, so it might be good.
There's more over here.
Nice, nice.
I think this is all of it, actually.
Yeah, I think so too.
Go, go.
Yay!
Okay, go go go go go go go go go run Run Oh yeah, who's been
taking care of the store while we've been doing this?
I'm trapped Oh, over here There we go Limbs can be destroyed
with me Oh, yeah Why are they saying that?
Oh wait, where do I put the trash down?
I think I will make this quick I gotta get back to work soon
Who's been pooping on the walls while we've been gone?
Everybody everybody has how super he's balding i notice yeah
buddy what's this oh
bored i am bored yes okay uh 59 what do you want me to say
about that i don't know i'm on break right now okay he seems
fine to me have we read the feelings yeah he's bored
Yeah, but he gets snarky about it when he asks him if
you're...
Our raiding is a 5.0, let's go.
Why does it keep asking for...
Oh, this guy...
People love this...
Are you okay?
His head is kind of...
Yeah.
Oh.
Dude, is this from gaming too hard?
We're sleeping wrong.
It's like...
Oh, yes.
He's got a little...
Oh, his necklace is also upside down.
Evening, friend.
Oh, I think...
You look tired.
long night.
Sometimes...
He's feeling peaceful and compassionate.
Youth pastor, where's a cross necklace?
This whole thing my mother gave it to me.
It's perfect.
What is...
My mother.
Oh, cervical dystonia.
That's why my head leans.
It's a muscle thing.
Wait.
No, he's fake.
He's fake.
It's upside down.
His crosses in the photo.
It's upright side up, but upside down right now.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, my gosh, you're so right.
He's fake.
Oh.
What do you do that, friend?
I only meant to help.
You only meant to help.
We got so many mobs.
Let's go.
Nice.
Why is the music so...
Oh, that's it?
I was fairly uneventful.
Yeah, nothing happened.
Did we...
Did we make our quota?
Yeah.
And we're making more, baby.
Yubi!
Oh, come on!
No!
How are you guys feeling now at the end of the shift?
Where are you?
I'm gotcha.
Traffic code.
I'm gonna scan you.
Oh, I always, I always, I need to not do this because my
gotcha look is actual trash.
Are you scanning me?
I'm gonna scan you.
I'm aroused.
You are still aroused.
You are busy right now and I cannot ask you why.
Yeah, why?
Am I feeling busy?
You are confused.
Confused?
Wait!
you're both around and i'm confused well i guess there's
there's the confusion right there i thought i thought by
default all player characters were around i thought so too
maybe it's the goose the goose the goose gang around it
could be it could be yeah yeah
i'm holding the orb of confusion
Thank you.
I guess we're good to go.
Yeah, spooky.
We can go, I guess, then, right?
Yeah, let's go.
Let's keep an eye out just in case it's not the real bus
again.
Yeah, I know, right?
They wouldn't do it two times in a row, no?
Demon bus.
Surely not.
Okay, I'm...
Oh, press it.
Okay.
Oh, yippee!
Oh, thank goodness.
That sounds like a good album name.
Oh, we did night six out of 13.
YAHOO!
Yippee!
We didn't kill any humans!
We did it then!
We did it!
I'll pay the bill.
Yeah, I'm paying the bill.
We lose.
Wait, we have so much money.
Yeah, we're doing great.
Yay!
They're coming back to join us!
Human doppelganger.
Yeah!
We did it.
Oh wow, the necklace was so big brain.
Speaks with the list.
Luckily we haven't killed, I don't think we've killed any
innocent civilians yet.
I don't think so either.
I think we've been really good about it.
Yahoo!
Yeah, goos!
Yippee!
Oh, that's my excuse, I missed you so much.
Money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money,
money, money, money, money.
side first yeah yeah any i hear something but the music is
always dodgy it is right yeah there's no more limbs out
there though nice we cleaned up the ball awesome oh what is
that like noise right that's what i was hearing
Huh?
Money, money, money, money, money.
Okay, it did actually add it.
Thank you.
Oh, it did.
It did.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm joking.
All right.
Oh, she's scamming me out of Tenkorn.
Wait, what?
Oh, check the notice board, it says.
Anything new to notice?
Oh, Cal and Matilda strike tomorrow.
What?
They talked about that guy, yeah.
Yeah, in that article in the car, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
residents urge to stay indoors as the eight approaches with
the calendar killer known to target eight victims on the 8th
of each month oh that's crazy oh our phones ringing hello
took you long enough to pick up couldn't find them phone
meat head a friend of mine is swinging by the store today
Louisa she has this condition where one leg is a lot longer
than the other she might walk weird and look suspicious but
don't worry about it Louisa if you heard her i swear you
won't live to see another shift oh god okay thieves there's
been a rise in thieving activity in the area some customers
might walk in take items and simply attempt to leave please
catch them before they leave you will be rewarded for
anything i saw a thing that was like, oh, I got a second
pistol for us, you guys.
Let's go!
Yeah.
Get a second gun to use during regular store hours.
Yuppie!
Thank you.
Yeah!
Hello, Keith.
Keith Hargreaves.
Train conductor.
I appear to be some... Okay, now I...
Now I...
You good?
Oh, no, I'm not.
Yeah, go.
City routes were great today.
Traffic behaved nice.
Down the back.
Gray's taking over a bit.
What's up?
You good?
E.
Oh, train conductor.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Do we have any information about when the trains go around
here?
Can't drive the bus without looking...
Wait.
Oh, he's fake.
He's fake.
He's fake!
Wait, wait, wait.
That's a cool looking pistol right there.
Gotta try a new pistol.
There we go.
Oh, sorry.
I grabbed the pistol.
We take his money and then we then we shoot him.
Revolver.
Yeah.
That's the strap maybe to make the money.
Goose, are you good?
Goose?
Is Goose in the bathroom?
Is that the goose those in the bathroom yeah there's nothing
maybe he cleans the the poops in here too hopefully oh god
please don't clean the i'm so sorry can you put some clothes
on oh does anyone have any decency in the combat days can i
catch them wait cash yeah catch him catch him catch oh
caught stealing he needed something to eat give back the
item give back the items Goose, watch out!
Goose, watch out!
Goose!
What's happening to Goose?
I thought he was gonna get...
What's happening?
I thought he was gonna get run over.
Oh god, Goose!
No!
Booker decoration!
My idiot boyfriend left me at the club.
Yeah, now she's drunk and pissed off.
Diane...
Wait!
I think she's okay though.
No, no.
No.
No, her face looks much different.
Right?
That's me.
Great photo.
Right.
Does that?
Does it look different?
Doesn't look...
Am I crazy?
I don't think it does.
Does my mascara bad, be honest.
Why does she have a different...
Probably fine, isn't it?
Maybe.
There is blood on the wall.
I'm crazy okay if you guys think so I mean I'm not 100%
confident but I'm pretty confident I think it's okay it's
the angle of the eyebrow maybe maybe her eyes look like more
what I don't know her eyebrows look wait a second hmm now
now I I'm like, is it the angle of the photo?
Right!
Like, her eyebrows are more angry right now.
Yeah, they do.
I mean, she did say she's angry.
Because she got left at the club, though.
Yeah, she did say.
Did you scan her feelings?
Oh, we don't have the scanner today, do we?
You can't, yeah.
I think she's probably okay.
Okay.
Should we let her through?
Let's let her through.
Okay.
That hint scares me.
I know, right?
Rat, rat, rat, rat, rat.
No, if you found a rat.
Shoot, where'd it go?
I'm stalking, I'm a good employee stalking.
Oh my god.
There's all the wall poo.
Oh, Louisa, is that their friend?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It says she had a weird thing with her leg.
Did she walk weird?
Oh, wow.
Oh, yeah, she does have a interesting thing with her leg.
Yeah.
He's let this leg thing I was born with it gotten used to it
at this point He didn't say what kind of leg thing.
Oh, yeah Right leg shorter than left leg Wait right leg
shorter than yeah, that is that is correct.
This is true.
That's a weird phrasing though, no like it which it wouldn't
it be like left leg is longer than or like
It feels like everything is suspicious now It is technically
correct, but it feels weird.
Sure, then, yeah, it does feel weird.
It's very confusing.
I think she's okay, though.
I think.
Okay.
I'm gonna say Louisa is probably fine.
We also don't want to lose our job.
We don't.
Wait, can we ask her about what's his name or?
Oh, good question, 71.
Oh, the guy?
Yeah.
Community college.
Bro, stop.
They're gonna go all the way over there.
Okay.
We're gonna let her go, guys.
Oh, there's another Louisa coming in.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh no.
I didn't say
that they were a friend of the managers.
no oh no oh my god oh no i knew it was a little that's not
fair i knew it i knew well
we we know this is the real one for real so we just uh let
her go gosh don't know oops
Such a funny sequence of events.
Grandma!
Look at her go!
Yeah!
Oh, she's so cute!
Yeah, go, Grandpa!
Look at her go!
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to tell everyone this is Densetsu.
Yeah!
Oh, you guys, we have somebody drinking the gasoline
outside!
What?
Um...
Oh, what's up, bitch?
No!
yeah hello what's up bitch okay I'm gonna leave those up to
our pets to clean up oh oh miss Marjorie cusses often only
walks with a cane likes to wear her hair in a bun but what
about the glasses oh she is cussing a lot yeah don't know
what to tell you about that wait no the glasses asking about
my glasses i just stole them wow love this lady i think
she's legit her cane is her style stick obviously dumbass
okay yeah i'm old bitch and what reminds me of my grandma i
think she might be my oshi wait what reminds me of my
grandma oh my god Aww.
Aww, grandma.
Aww.
Love her.
I think she's okay.
Thank you to your grandma for visiting the store.
Yeah, thanks grandma.
Yeah.
Obviously, Thomas.
Okay.
Have a good night, grandma.
We might need to buy more stock boxes.
She's back!
Sonny.
That was the...
The doppelganger!
Oh, a car's pulled up.
Hello.
Oh.
Hello there.
Oh, hi Raiders!
Thank you!
Well, thank you, Suki, for eating that.
Come
on, give me a big one.
Yes!
We need to mop that.
Thank you for the captain, you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
No, Remy.
We're not a restaurant here.
Anyone know what the flashlight is?
Oh, my God.
Oh, there's one right here.
Yeah, there's always one right there, yeah.
I was like, who's that?
Running around with some kind of weapon.
And it was just Phoebe with the mall.
Tools.
Oh, wait, what's this?
What is this?
Janet Davis.
The Davis family invites you to join them in celebrating
Janet's life at a memorial service.
funeral invite that's the funeral i'm coming from the poor
woman it was a fatal heart attack that did it i was there
when it happened so awful i like to keep janet davis i'm
gonna go check yeah lp7s oh l lp7s
cause of death mutilation janet davis I think this guy...
I think maybe we should kill him.
I think we should kill him.
Got him.
Nice, too nice.
Time to mop that up.
Yeah.
Our pets are taking...
Feast of my pretties.
They're starving.
Maybe this is why they need the medicine they have.
Yeah, maybe.
What's happening to our pets?
Oh my god, wait, what?
Is this the real one again?
Is she back?
Huh?
Oh hi.
What do you mean?
Again?
Is it our game bug?
Oh, go over it too, it's such a good jump.
Are game bugs maybe?
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Right leg shorter than left leg.
Hang on.
Yeah, it is.
No?
Yes.
Yes, it is.
Right leg short.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Where's 12, 1971?
Wait, was the other Louisa?
Was it the other leg or something?
No, it was still correct.
So that's why I'm like...
Oh, I wish the picture showed her legs.
I, no shirt, no shoes, no service.
Yeah.
It's a little confusing.
Maybe we let her go.
There's no way that the other one was actually the real one.
But what if the game bugged because we got four in a row?
It is a lot of Louisa's.
Very suspicious.
Yeah.
I think we're getting an anomaly tonight.
I think we are going to be a bug.
I think the game is bugged.
I'm just going to...
Except...
I think we've got a letter through, though.
I don't see anything suspicious.
Yeah, me neither.
Hello, sir.
Oh, rat.
You got it?
Wow.
Whoa, what happened there?
That's a little rat.
Yeah, just...
Oh, no!
Who's pooping in the bathroom?
Hello?
Hello.
Just stocking up on one?
My two little ones.
Hmm.
what's your name sorry yeah mother of two and ken are her
baby's names apparently what was it look lee and ken are her
baby's names can't wait what's her name sorry oh collins
yeah i don't see any oh leo leo and ben collins leo and ben
says 1990 yeah so maybe ben She said different names.
What did she say?
Yeah, what did she say?
She said Lee and Ken.
Instead of Leo and Ben.
Oh.
Wait, Collins.
Leo?
Ask about him?
What an odd question?
Yeah, who's three years old?
My little boy Lee already turned three this year.
No, no.
She don't even know her child's name.
She don't even know her kid's name.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, shoot her!
Oh, I was gonna take her money first.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, you can do that?
I think we, I think we're over quota.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Yeah, just trying to get extra money.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, we can take their money and that's big tongue.
Big tongue.
What?
Ever wonder where adult bullgangers come from?
Where do they come from?
Victor Hale?
Why don't you have a photo?
He's a private investigator.
Oh.
Wait, interesting.
That is what they said.
They come from negative emotions or something.
A couple weeks later, every second.
The dentist involved was dead.
Just torn off.
The dentist!
Oh.
You just stabbed him, Faby.
Oh, did I?
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
So, Juni, thank you for the rain.
I love you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the rain.
I always evade Net when they try to take pictures of me.
I don't particularly trust them.
I think this guy is legit.
March 21st.
I think he's legit.
I don't see any problems.
Yeah, I don't either.
I'm going to accept it.
Stay aware, he says.
For us later on as well.
Yeah, I feel like because he seems like a character or like
a lore character.
Yeah.
Like, he'll come back.
I think so, too.
Oh, I'm stalking.
Oh, shelf already full.
I wonder what happens if you accidentally kill, like, a main
character in this game.
That's a very good question.
Evening.
Been a busy night?
Yes.
Yes, it has, Linda.
Oh, she has heracromia.
Oh,
that's so cool.
blue green blue hello then you asking about my hair it's not
naturally red red eye tattoo on her left hand
oh she does she has a tattoo on her hand oh okay it means
i've got different colored eyes similar to your job except
the whole killing people thing we got net grunts who hang
around our store to deal with that stuff they're not the
nicest people
People say...
People keep saying she dresses like a medieval villager.
I don't see it, dude.
I kind of see it.
Well, I'm with a shirt a little bit.
Yeah.
I kind of see it.
I think she's good.
Yeah, she seems good.
Yeah, okay.
I'm 25.
25.
Yeah, that seems right.
No?
We're getting so many good reviews on y'all.
Whoa.
Was that not good?
Oh, man.
I know it.
You wouldn't say that, you don't think that both of those
friends are the manager.
Oh, no.
We're fake.
No, no, no.
I have some wood in my arms.
Oh, our pets, though.
What do our pets do?
Oh no, would they be okay?
I'm going to put this here.
I'm going to put this.
Okay, you guys, watch out.
I'm going to put this down on here.
I'm leaving a trap.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I got to pick it up, actually.
I'll leave it here.
And I'll hide in here.
Stay safe.
Oh, someone grab, or I'll grab the shotgun.
There's another gun by the way.
the guns though okay where are we hiding bathroom anywhere
oh
there's two
what is that
there's a metra chameleon there's a metra chameleon
I shot the metra chameleon nice oh
dead dead yeah okay No, we got to get the met.
Oh, no, we're good.
Okay.
Never mind.
And our pets were safe.
Our pets are safe.
Oh, yay.
Wait, no, it was great teamwork, then.
Yeah.
Yeah, good job.
Good job, team.
Yeah.
We didn't even need this one.
I don't know if I saw the Misha Chameleon, though.
You didn't?
I didn't.
He was like...
I know there were two creatures, but...
Yeah, there was... He was on the wall.
I got him.
Oh, God.
Good job.
Oh, gosh.
That scared me.
Yay, the dollars!
Our quota was $60 and we made 273, guys.
Oh, it's supposed to be 283!
Oh yeah.
I'm very intrigued to see who was the real...
The real Louisa.
Me too!
I hope we got it right.
Hopefully.
We let through two.
Yeah.
So maybe we got the...
Does that mean we killed the innocent?
Who knows?
Oh, is it this boy?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Yeah.
Goose, let's go home.
Oh.
Remember, this could be a fake bus.
Yeah.
With the fake bus driver.
I think it's all right though.
I think it's all right.
Yeah.
Oh.
Heck yeah!
Yahoo!
Woohoo!
Okay, so the first one we let through, the second one we let
through.
through the third one we killed in the fourth okay no humans
killed right somehow no humans killed news broadcast news
broadcast oh no oh oh gosh oh no oh stay safe stay inside
stay alert okay two days remain until goose okay medical
boom we got it
out okay okay then what about the other one it's they both
said human so she we killed all the right ones wait which
one did we huh I think the game we did it right it's just
she came twice and was like hi I'm a friend of the manager
why did she say that again like she was a new person but
yeah but we we didn't let in two dot or didn't we we didn't
get let two doppelgangers go so The game is glitched.
I think so.
Yeah, the game bugged for real.
Wait, we- It put us- Wow.
It tested us, but we were too strong.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, someone says we answered the phone twice at the same
time.
So that's what bugged the game.
Oh.
Oh, no!
What?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
no what that's crazy but i think we did let that first girl
go even though it says dead now but we did let her go we did
let her go but we did but i don't know why because we killed
her the second time maybe it reset i don't know i'll take it
i'll take it oh yeah whatever sure i mean we were fine we
did everything we were good we didn't kill any humans yeah
we were good grandma was real nice yeah we're good this game
for them this probably will be our last night though i
imagine yeah last night because then then we'll be about
like halfway right and then we can yeah we can do the other
nights another time perhaps yeah i want to eat before the
meeting too yeah We got places to be after this.
Yeah, sorry, guys.
Idle meeting.
Oops.
Money.
Money, money, money.
Finding all the money, money.
Money, money, money, money.
Oh, no friends out here tonight.
Roadwork delays.
Oh.
Obituary section.
Stacey Kennedy.
Okay, guys.
Stacey Kennedy died this week.
week i think she will probably visit it might not be in the
database yeah yeah yeah yeah stacy kennedy i'll remember
yeah and roadwork delays okay stacy kennedy chat help us out
help a group out oh roadworks delays expected okay so if
anyone's like oh the road it was all fine roaches we have
roaches We got a squash road trip.
Oh, no, no, no.
Ooh, pretty pink.
Ooh, nice.
I like the hose.
Yeah.
That'll be really nice, actually, for them.
Oh, it's our favorite guy.
I know, right?
Clyde!
There's Clyde!
Calendar Killer.
Stay alert tonight.
Yeah.
Two serial killers are active.
is spread to them.
Oh yeah, the dentist and the calendar killer, huh?
Oh, someone said the hose counts.
The hose counts as a mop for the roaches, too.
Oh, that's nice.
Yeah.
Oh, hello.
Hello, sir.
How may I help you?
Can I get $8 on gas, please?
Oh, yes.
Permission square.
Haven't been able to wash them for a while.
You're fine.
I didn't ask.
Oh, 2-9-4-1.
Yeah, I got it.
2-9-4-1.
wagon extremely rusty and dirty okay that's that's checks
out junk food dog bed bring it in bring those deliveries
okay wait we're down wait what do you mean we're down to 499
it is it illegal to get a little peckish now and again Times
have been a little rough.
No paychecks coming in, so I gotta sleep in the car.
Oh, buddy.
Oh, no.
What's this?
You can open the car hood, too.
Oh, you can.
What?
Whoa.
What happened?
Oh, you trying to hose.
We have power wash.
Yeah, yeah.
You can get the roaches with that even.
You're good to go, buddy.
Come on.
Thank you very much.
Oh.
I am not excited for the roaches.
Me neither.
They're definitely gonna do, like, one of those, like, the
rat event.
We'll need that, for sure, for getting the roaches.
Hello, I am Jade.
Hi, Jade.
I am Jade.
You do not look anything like your photo, Jade.
Uh, it's an extreme tan.
It's...
I am merely underwent...
She merely went underwent...
Human puberty!
Wait, let me check her out and I'll kill her.
Let me check her out and I'll kill her.
Oh wait.
Cuberty these days goes hard, huh?
My facial hurt.
Stream dead.
Wait, am I good?
Hmm?
Am I streaming?
Are you good?
Oh.
Cool, good?
Yeah, I think so.
I think I'm okay.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Um, anyway.
Whoa!
Oh, is that a bear?
Guys, is that a bear?
What is with us and attracting bears?
This isn't even the right game for that.
Hello?
It's awesome.
Should I try scaring off with some water?
No, he's purchasing.
He's a...
Okay.
I mean, if he's a paying customer.
Good evening.
My name is Herbert.
What a splendid...
What a splendid shop you have here.
I enjoy shops.
Other humans often do.
I kind of love him.
Oh, I like him.
I love him too.
Wait, wait.
His ID is a leaf.
Clothes.
Oh dear, you had forgotten something.
He's a student.
I don't wanna...
A student of the world.
him so i don't want to shoot him yeah me too
i wish we could let him go i don't want to go through
another event obviously i'm sorry yeah sorry buddy oh that
was very rude oh he's gone oh oh oh well maybe he's fine
he's he was resilient I think he would have run anyway I'm
probably I don't know if we would have been able to kill him
then either I wonder if we were supposed to bear trap him I
don't know David Kennedy wait isn't that the person didn't
someone die oh my twin sister could use a job yeah it was
Stacey Kennedy yeah Stacey Kennedy died is he 24 like she
was because other otherwise it might not be his yeah oh
that's good that's big brain that's big brain oh no he's
older oh you're right maybe it is fine then wait no no he
wouldn't be older right he should be he should guys sorry my
stream keeps going out hold on no it's okay take your time
oh stacy kennedy is also 1953 is it the same day Yes.
I thought that she just died and she was 24.
Hold on.
Let me double check this article real quick.
Seems to be regional.
Okay, I'm sorry.
They are born on the same day though.
24 passed away unexpectedly this week.
Fake Ivy.
This week she died.
No, but they're, it says they're like 40.
Huh?
I guess it's here they're 40 years old are there other
Kennedys is it another Stacy Kennedy maybe
it is another Stacy Kennedy are we sure there can't be more
than one that would be way too confusing yeah right I don't
know either way right his twin sister who's born on the same
day is dead as well yeah that's That's true.
Either way, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he's suspicious either way because...
Because if they were born on the same...
Stacey's dead, so he...
Wait, let's ask about his sister because...
My sister currently at home.
Yeah, he's not real because...
No, no, bro, no, bro, no, no, no, no.
Suss, sussie, sussie, sussie, sussie, fucker.
There we go.
Just took out the trash.
Ooh, power washing is fun.
Power washing is fun.
wait there's a dog wait we don't we don't have our dogs
right no we got another another dog oh another cockroach oh
we got another another animal customer rough rough he says
bless you oh so sweet hi look at the little picture of tofu
service dog oh wait that's so sweet silver-lined service
currently currently serving charles wiggle bottom he is a
dog he is a dog right so cute rough he's like four years old
wait this is so cute i'm gonna quickly look up wiggle bottom
oh yes yeah do it definitely make sure he's real
alive charles wiggle bottom retired yeah he's all
interesting unable to leave his house ah yeah so this is
probably doing a grocery run for this guy this is real this
is good bye-bye it's good that was so cute oh he's looking
out for his his masters very sweet yeah hello what the heck
was that see something was it me bouncing around i think
just someone spawned like on my head oh no oh oh are you
restocking i'm restocking too oh she looks so sad her face
is so judith oh why picking up picking up food for your
husband carol oh no oh dear are you okay your makeup's
running oh gosh why are you He looks so sad.
Picking up for her husband?
No, wait.
Her husband's dead.
Oh, yes, I forgot.
Yes, he's actually dead.
Oh, I must just be a bit tired of my mind, silly me.
What if it's trauma?
I know, right?
What if she just can't accept his dad?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Too many roaches and cats.
Oh, I'm just trying to grab them too.
got him thank you i think sent her to him oh my gosh you
sound like my husband oh no i think i don't think i think
it's i think it's doppelganger i think it's gotta be
doppelganger surely yeah i think so i don't think you forget
like yeah she said I forgot like that's so that feels a
little suspicious yeah
hmm hello there greetings may I purchase these fine
alcoholic beverages this evening how old I like this girl
yeah I'm hoping this is Marcus Thompson.
Look at his shirt!
Any...
Any cattle?
Any cattle.
Oh, I don't think that's Marcus Thompson.
Yes, I train people personally all day.
His outfit makes me look shorter.
Yes, I have a sleeper build.
A sleeper build?
Old enough to buy these beers.
I don't think...
So does doppelganger mean he's pretending to be someone else
or he's a monster because i don't think he's a monster i
don't think so either okay wait let's look at the thompson's
there's also douglas oh yeah unless he's unless he's dead oh
true true true marcus thompson darla thompson rory thompson
oh wait but there's marcus yeah oh yeah because it could be
this could be this nine-year-old Douglas Thompson we ask oh
yeah
oh true hmm what do we do in this could we just not sell him
the beer I don't know if we can reject like this is like his
brother Yeah, just based on, are you the person, this idea?
I guess we have to shoot him, but...
I'll do it.
Oh!
It had to be done.
Are you sure?
Oh, no.
Did it have to be done?
Three, dog.
Three?
Win!
Oh.
Come on.
Wait, do we have enough stuff to like...
Do we have boards and stuff?
Yeah.
When did we let three?
I think the game is bugged.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, I think the game is bugged.
It's a faux show.
Poop on the wall.
No, Phoebe, we don't have time!
What is this?
I'm getting in the bed.
My five stars, Yelp readings.
We're double packing, we're double packing.
I think so, yeah.
Good job, team.
Let's take them out.
Yeah, we got this.
You kidding me?
Baby!
Ah!
Wait, there's babies!
There's a baby!
Oh, baby!
Oh, my God.
Oh, they're babies.
Why are they even talking about?
There's so many babies, there's so many babies.
Babies!
Oh, hey, baby, baby.
Ah!
Good thing I got us more health, right?
Oh, we have to get rid of the rest of them.
Oh, dear.
Oh, no!
No!
Dang it!
I got you.
I'm holding Revive.
Thank you!
Oh, my gosh!
Wait, where's the rest of them?
Oh, that guy.
I don't know where my...
I don't know where my weapon went.
Oh, yippee!
Oh, my goodness!
Yay!
Your shift is done.
I am so intrigued to see these three doppelgangers.
Yeah, me too!
Me too!
I guess let's clean up a little bit before the night.
You see, a mommy entity and a daddy entity love each other
very much.
Okay.
Who is loving each other?
The mommy and daddy entities love each other very much.
Man.
I think we got everything.
I'm gonna go throw my trash away and then I'm on the road.
Oh wait, there's a bloodstain on the wall.
Just got attacked.
Restock's shelves.
A baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do.
You sold items to doppelgangers and killed them.
It doesn't count as...
It doesn't count?
Well, we killed it.
Uh-oh.
It doesn't count if we sell the items.
Oh.
We need money.
Then maybe.
But it's been saying, like, complete or deceased.
So maybe that's why it's confusing us.
Oh.
Sometimes you just gotta do these things for the money,
alright?
Yeah, we got the money.
We're tanking this guy.
We're fine.
I am so excited to do this.
see who we screwed up on.
I don't think we did.
Also, that...
Well, I don't think we did.
We just took the money, which apparently we're not allowed
to do.
Yeah.
Human!
See!
I told you!
That was his brother!
That was his kid brother!
Oh, well, the character only cost $15, isn't it, though?
Despite matching up their recurring killing patterns, it
seems that the calendar killer did not strike for the first
time in six months, as the calendar killer lost their nerve.
Or we got him.
Maybe we were the calendar killer oh i took out the eighth
victim well the eighth of this month is my birthday so maybe
they held off my birthday yeah dog yeah but what we meant to
do just let him get away with it wait how do you know how
are you supposed to know his name yeah how are you supposed
to know his name maybe you ask him about it And he goes
like, oh, wait, my name is actually...
Like, he's... Maybe he messes up.
I killed a child.
Yeah, maybe he's even tearing at you.
And it costs 15 bucks.
Listen.
Don't try and buy drink when you're underage, guys.
Yeah, you might get shot.
This is a lesson for you all.
Yeah.
Yeah, that'll learn.
The subtitles reveal his name.
Okay, to be fair, I'm running around.
Everybody's running around.
some people are asking questions yeah the subtitles show his
name i feel so stupid i feel so dumb
whoopsie it's fine it's guilty by having your sick pet in
the bottom left corner yeah we're doing it for the games by
the way wait who didn't do anything who besides that who
besides that did we mess up on no no but they were saying
that because like sometimes i'll take the money and then
shoot them that's what it's yeah that's what's the confusion
oh i see yeah i see yeah someone said the calendar killer
was probably the kid so we did a good job yeah yeah see yeah
in a world where not matching your id means death he had it
coming i think so too the kid was just played stupid you
yeah that's a faffo moment i think sorry buddy I did like
his shirt.
We should have taken his shirt after we should have.
We should have.
Yeah, too bad he exploded, right?
We should have all got that shirt.
Yeah.
I'm going to click next shift and then see if that will,
like, save, and then we can...
Ah, okay.
Got it.
Yeah, I think it saves.
Okay.
I'd love to complete this another time, though.
I know.
I think we're really good at it.
We're really good at it.
Yeah, are we?
We're quite good.
Yeah.
We take the money and we beat the monsters.
We don't need to be careful.
Yeah!
Let's do what our hearts command us to.
I'm gonna quit to menu.
I just didn't want to kill a child.
Yeah, quit to menu.
Okay, we can move the Discord if it kicks us.
Yes.
Quit to menu?
Yep.
Oh, I think it kicked everybody.
Hello?
Yes, hello.
Hello.
I'm turning you guys off again in Discord, eh?
I hear you.
Hello.
Hi.
I think it's saved.
That was so fun.
That was really, really fun.
It saved.
We're so good.
Let's do it again next time.
We're so good at this.
So good at this game, guys.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for next time.
I'm going to skedaddle since we have our meeting in 30.
Yeah, I'm going to skedaddle and eat as well.
Yeah.
But we need to eat.
Thank you, everybody, for joining us.
We're good at the game, huh?
We are.
at uh running a store and and killing monsters and
definitely not humans and especially not human children yes
that was a child totally right i was just following in big
boss's steps of metal gear i think i gotta play metal gear
but uh yeah good job you guys yeah great shift and we have
five
Yippee!
I'll see you guys in 30, I guess.
See you guys very soon!
Yeah, I'll see you soon!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!
Fake neat, thank you!
Suss it broke earlier though, are you really mean to all?
Need to ask a few questions.
One, what's your birthday?
Two, what do you want for dinner?
Three, what hairpin news has you excited today?
My birthday is October 1st!
I want curry for dinner.
That's my leftovers.
And my hairpin news is I have a collab with Obake Noo at one
of my favorite stores in Japan, Village Vanguard.
Wait, can I just gush about that for a second?
The Metsha Chameleon guy was there the whole night.
You walked past him at least three times.
No way!
Wait, that's so freaky!
I only saw him that one moment.
Okay, so I have a collab with with this with this store
called Village Vanguard right and Village Vanguard oh my
gosh when I got the email I sent it to Steiner my manager
and I was like is this is this legit because I can't even
tell you how many times I have gone to Village Vanguard in
Japan it is like a legendary store for idols in particular
they they often hold when an idol releases a new single
they'll hold like like new single like events where you can
where you can go and like see them perform and if you buy
the CD like you get like a handshake and things like that so
it's really like an iconic location it's a pilgrimage site
for real for real and so they they emailed me and they were
like wow some of us in the store are big fans of mint and we
are really inspired by your love of idols and otakunis and
we would like and we have this brand called Obakinu and I
was like oh my gosh I love Obakinu I love Obakinu and I've
been keeping this in for like so many months now like a
whole year now probably and and they were like we would love
to collab with you and Obakinu and I was like wait this is
like this is this is like a dream collab for me and so i was
i was like this is oh my gosh so yeah to be i like i said
every japan trip i basically i go to village vanguard and i
look around and i they they would have like a bunch of
dempagumi stuff and um and i've seen so many idols at
village vanguard and now i get to see myself in village
vanguard could you maybe pin the link for pre-orders real
quick for non-twitter folks oh i have to get it i have to
get it first but it's truly like a dream a dream collab for
me so it's very very crazy um to have it uh it is a japanese
store so i believe you need Ba'i or something, some other
sort of service, if you did want to get the goods.
They said that they were going to see how many people
pre-order, how well pre-orders go, before putting me in the
store itself.
So if pre-orders go well, then I will be in the store
itself, which would be really cool.
Ba'i doesn't work, but others do.
Oh, my mistake then.
Wait, but it...
Bayee shows up on the store for me, on the thing.
Village Vanguard has Bayee built into their site, so it's
pretty convenient.
Oh, okay, cool, cool.
Hmm.
Yeah, Bayee does work if you like to use that.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Like a specific store or all of them?
They gave me a list.
It was like a couple stores.
A couple stores, but I did request like...
the shibuya one because that's the one that's the one i go
to um so often there's a very cool mural in there done by an
artist that i've always wanted to work with so um yeah it's
like yeah it's really it's really crazy even if you just
like comment on it being like sugoi on the twitter i think
that would really help if you can't um afford to get the
item that's totally fine even if you're like and kind of
show how excited you are to see it yeah so thank you I was
like this is such a surreal I should take a picture I own so
many Village Vanguard books when you go they have free
Village Vanguard books And I liked, I collected them for
many, for a really, really long time.
And actually, one of my, like, my, my, well, she's, she's, I
get to see her only sometimes, but she graduated.
But one of my, like, really important Oishi to me, she had a
contest to be, like, in those magazines.
And so I would fight every day.
I would wake up and I would vote for her.
And I would, I would fight.
I would, I would be like, everybody go vote for my Oishi,
things like that.
you know, Village Vanguard is a really special place for
idol fans, and I'm like, oh my gosh, I can't believe they
reached out to me.
I can't believe they reached out to me.
Ah, this is Comic-Ce all in the same week.
It's kind of insane.
Oh, I'm a little overwhelmed.
I'm a little overwhelmed, but it's really awesome.
If you go to Japan, Village Vanguard is a very cool store.
It's a noisy bookstore.
They have lots of really cool stuff.
So I just recommend going in general, even if I wasn't
sponsored.
I feel like I've recommended them before, so I'm not even
sponsored, though, technically.
Like, I'm just collabing with them, but, um, yeah.
Really, really crazy, really, really cool stuff.
Wow.
Wowi.
And what timing, too.
I feel like it's really cool because, you know, um, maybe my
influence in Japan will raise a little bit.
it.
I love Obakinu!
Yeah!
Me too!
Proud of you, boss.
Thank you.
Thanks for the fun streaming, though.
As anyone told you how adorable you were shooting those
nasty skinwalkers was real fun.
I got six shots and I only one.
Could open the door for more.
Wow!
Who is me?
Thank you!
A bit ago I donated and I kind of...
Wait, I lost kind of bad at blackjack well today i want it
back and then some take this as thanks for all the times i'm
watching this stream of learning to count cards congrats you
should wait how much did you win then let's go and then some
let's go so happy for you minto congratulations thank you
thank you dreadnought welcome back to thank you so much yeah
really crazy I think this is all that I've had to announce
for like big, big, big stuff though.
So you can...
That is all that I have.
Oh, wait.
No, I have one more.
Segoyito is so cool.
I have one more thing in the upcoming months.
In the upcoming months.
Yes.
One more thing that I can think of.
So.
But for now, I'm going to go eat.
And then I have my meeting in 20 minutes.
So thank you guys so much.
I'm so glad that we could do Dentsa 2.
We were such a good team.
We worked together so well.
I love Mickey and Phoebe.
I love them so much.
We were rooting, tooting, shooting.
We were big brain in.
Vicky was like tanking that spider so much.
I kept buying health for us because I was like, she's just
going to keep tanking it.
So your answers, check out.
Be safe out there.
But congrats on the awesome Wabuckianu news.
I will post about it in the community thing.
And the Comiket stuff as well.
I requested, I saw some of the Comiket stuff was already
selling out.
So I requested if maybe they could set aside some of the
merch for myself so that I can do the raffle for you guys.
guys.
So much cool stuff in my ocean keeps winning.
Minto's so cool.
How does she do it?
I don't... I'm not cool at all!
Thank you, loves.
I'm just an otaku that is getting thrown into stuff.
It's kind of crazy.
I am just an otaku, and yet...
Yeah.
Was listening to your collab while driving for work?
This game sounds very chaotic.
Good luck with work, Scoobagator!
Nah.
So kakui!
Minto the best?
Not even!
No, no, no, no!
Unstoppable, Taku.
Crazy, crazy.
Break it till you make it, maybe.
Minto is cool and cute and amazing, man.
Now, make sure to keep some of the that merch for you too oh
yeah i want to keep a little bit of it for me too yeah of
course just an otaku no you're the otaku i i requested like
3 000 ish dollars worth of stuff so so hopefully hopefully
um i want to do the raffle where you know you can you'll
only win one thing right um so uh so but i wanted to make
sure that i got enough stuff that lots of people will
hopefully get um get a prize so yeah which is the coolest
and most good no just an otaku know you're the otaku with
proof no
will it be signed by you i didn't think about that it might
be a lot to sign for me though i'm currently having to sign
300 postcards for skyline serenade
So, maybe a little tricky for me to sign the Comic-Ket stuff
as well.
But yeah, I'm gonna go eat.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Pick one grand prize.
Yeah, maybe we'll have like a lucky prize, the luckiest
prize, right?
Thank you guys so much.
Oh, it's a meato!
Thank you guys for shipped at midnight.
We will hopefully do this again.
The three of us.
Yeah, this was fine.
This was really fun.
So What's up, up, up, up, up, up meet up, up, meet up.
Thank you guys so much.
What's up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Bye-bye.